this is Jocko podcast number 218 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening in the Marine
Corps in Vietnam first and the second
lieutenants made up about 65% of the
Marine officers killed in action now if
you if you add captain's Marine Corps
captain's Oh threes on to that you get
to about 85% of all Marine officers
killed in Vietnam were in these these
relatively junior ranking officers these
were the platoon and company commanders
and if you go to 1968 1968 was the year
with the highest number of Americans
killed in action in Vietnam 16,000 899
that's over 1400 per month 1,400 per
month killed in action now to put that
in perspective a little bit during the
heaviest fighting when I was in Iraq
which was in 2006 there was 823
Americans killed now obviously every
single loss is a is a tragedy
but during the Vietnam War the tragedy
was 20x that number 20 times more people
killed in 1968 in Vietnam than there
were in Iraq in 2006 that is just a it's
just a different level now in total in
Vietnam there were four
tene thousand eight hundred and thirty
six Marines killed one thousand three
hundred and eighty seven of those were
officers so that's basically ten percent
of the Marines killed or officers and as
I already said eighty five percent of
them were these junior officers now if
you just run that mouth math out a
little bit there's generally around
gonna be one officer in an infantry
platoon and there's gonna be around
forty guys which means that these
officers make up for about 2.5 percent
of Marines and then again just by my
estimation just some rough math that
means that these young marine officers
were about four times more likely to be
killed than the enlisted guys and you if
you think about that you know you wonder
what why is that how's that happened
well from from a tactical perspective
first of all the enemy knows what I say
all the time and that is that leadership
is the most important thing on the
battlefield and because of that the
enemy aims to kill the leaders and then
on top of that marine officers are
trained to be the first one on the
ground the first one that's off the
helicopter the first one that's out of
the vehicle the first one in in the
combat situation and then the last to
leave the last load the helicopter the
last to get inside of an APC so right
there your chances go up because you're
in it longer and that might only be an
extra thirty seconds but those moments
when you're inserting you're extracting
from the battlefield those are the most
critically dangerous moments usually and
then on top of all that you add to the
fact that as an officer you generally
lead from
somewhere near the front of the patrol
maybe you're behind the point man maybe
you're behind the point man in the first
automatic weapons gunner and since
you're in the front of the patrol well
that increases your exposure to booby
traps it increases your exposure to
ambushes and then of course on top of
all those things when the time comes you
actually have to lead you actually have
to step up you actually have to make
decisions you actually have to get your
men to maneuver on the battlefield
that's what your job is and by the way
that job district description is not
just some theoretical job description
this is what the marine the young marine
officers in Vietnam actually did then
here's a here's an example of what a
young Marine Corps officer did in
Vietnam the President of the United
States of America takes pleasure in
presenting the Silver Star to second
lieutenant Charles Robert Eisen back the
United States Marine Corps for
conspicuous gallantry and intrepidity in
action while serving as platoon
commander with Company D 1st
Reconnaissance Battalion first Marine
Division FMF in connection with
operations against the enemy in the
Republic of Vietnam on 4 July 1968
second lieutenant Eisenbach was leading
a reconnaissance patrol when the unit
suddenly came under intense small-arms
and automatic weapons fire from a
numerically superior north vietnamese
army force and the lead elements were
pinned down realizing the seriousness of
the situation he immediately directed
the remainder of his men to maneuver
to aid the beleaguered Marines while he
fearlessly moved forward to direct the
fire of his men ignoring the enemy fire
impacting around him he moved about the
fire-swept terrain deploying his men
into advantageous firing positions and
directing their fire until he was
seriously wounded although he was
partially paralyzed and unable to move
he continued to direct his men while
simultaneously adjusting airstrikes and
supporting artillery fire upon the
hostile positions disregarding his
painful injury he resolutely controlled
his unit throughout the remainder of the
firefight his heroic and timely actions
were an inspiration to all who observed
him and contributed significantly to the
accomplishment of his unit's mission by
his courage superb leadership and
unwavering devotion to duty in the face
of great personal danger
second lieutenant Aizen Beck upheld the
highest traditions of the Marine Corps
and of the United States Naval Service
[Music]
now when you hear an award write up like
that
you kind of have to ask yourself who who
are these men where did these men come
from where did they learn this level of
courage and bravery and where did they
learn to lead well there's an honor to
say that today we have one of those men
with us as a matter of fact we have that
man the man whose silver star citation I
just read his name is Charles Robert
Eisenbach
or Ike as he was known and he's here to
share his story so that we can learn
some of the lessons from him about
leadership and about life Ike
thanks for coming on appreciate it my
pleasure
great great to meet you and luckily your
your son and your daughter put together
a bunch of information kind of a
timeline of your life which made it
really easy for me to prepare for this
podcasts because that's normally what I
have to go back and do but Matt
appreciate you doing that not a problem
and it starts off where I where I always
like to start off these podcasts in the
beginning so sir let's talk about your
childhood let's talk about like what was
young Ike doing where'd you come from
what young Ike wasn't around but young
bob lazar Bobby because I was Bob with
Bobby to the family before I went in the
service and then about a week into the
Naval Academy bleep summer
squad leader got us all out one night
and gave us nicknames some stuck some
didn't like stuck so that's the way that
was but when Bobby was growing up but
Bobby's dad was a current naval officer
and just somewhere just to the right of
Attila the Hun I would say it was a it
was a hard man but we had an interesting
childhood moved every couple of years
back and forth the East Coast West Coast
spent a couple of years and Lima Peru
and ended up in at Subic Bay and the
Philippines graduated from high school
out there so it was an interesting
childhood did so was he was he in World
War two he was he was a naval aviator he
out of the Naval Academy class of 36
flew PB wise as he used to say flying
used to be fun you know he had put on
the silk scarf go up 45 minutes or so I
said then somebody invented this damn
PBY which stayed aloft for 12 hours and
flying was not so much fun after that
but that's that's what he did in World
War two he was in the Olongapo in the
Philippines when the war broke with this
squadron which I think was VP 101 they
kind of got out just by the hair of
their chinny chin chin worked their way
south down the Philippine Islands to
Java current-day Indonesia and then end
up in Perth Australia from there he
think he came back to the US for about a
year and did whatever they did with
folks in the world war two back then and
went back picked up command of a
seaplane tender the San Pablo and worked
his way back up the specific with a
MacArthur's group I think it was the
Battle of Leyte Gulf not as a combatant
because there's such seaplane tender
doesn't ever you know 1 or 2 5-inch guns
are they they didn't go out there and
shoot it up with anybody we hope not no
no yeah they carried a bagasse and
ammunition so that wouldn't have been a
pretty picture after world war ii you
know came back i didn't he didn't see me
until I was a year old I guess I didn't
know what I look like because he said my
mom's pictures were just nothing blur
so and we just picked up the family from
there started moving sister was born a
couple years later after after I was
born in Arlington Virginia I said we
cope we come back to Cara Knott Oh once
or twice you know before they rich
before that's right it was the it was
the ferry back then and that was a big
deal of course when you're a little kid
that was very fun you know when Europe
when you're a parent I guess they're
just a pain in the butt because you're
trying to get back and forth to Coronado
from San Diego on a time schedule
it's how long how long did he stay in
for he was in for 26 years had a heart
attack out in the Philippines his last
duty station and back in the 60s a heart
attack was you were just automatic
medical retirement so they shipped him
back to Newport and he was retired
probably up to about 27 28 years how old
were you at this point I was in first
year college the University of Utah when
he had his heart attack I went into the
Naval Academy the following year so when
you were growing up were you thinking
about I mean obviously if you went to
the University of Utah where you did you
want to go in the Navy at that point
well my my dad being my dad you know he
had prepped me for the Naval Academy
you know we visited there when I was
younger and everything like that and
when I was about a junior in high school
he would start with them well Bobby yeah
why didn't I do that be a graduate from
high school and you know I didn't have a
good answer no answer was gonna be just
right I knew what the answer should be
but so but I eventually I started to say
well dad I think I'm gonna go to college
that kind of satisfied him for a few
months and then he came back and said
well who do you thinks gonna pay for
that well I had me stumped for another
couple of months but to finally by the
end of my junior year I said dad you
know I think you're gonna pay for it and
so that's who stopped that so we're
gonna have the Philippines graduate from
high school out there has 17 in my
graduating class all-time high for
George Dewey junior senior high school
and I still you know I wasn't gonna go
to the Naval Academy us that this wasn't
in my scheme of things so three of us
got accepted the University of Utah I
went the University of Utah because it
was the one school that accepted me out
of high school I'm not that I had bad
grades or anything I had decent grades
and good recommendations but that's just
you know the way things worked out in
the early 60s this was 62 when I
graduated from high school so three of
us went off from are graduating from my
graduating class after just Salt Lake
City and were enrolled as freshmen at
the University of Utah
there was a get-together of all the
freshmen before schools officially
started and no know who was up there on
the stage but he was touting the
diversity back that of their entering
class and so he'd have you stand up and
said am i half free gentleman here from
the Philippines we're just damn pleased
so that's three Gringo's kind of stood
up and girl look at this like you're
from the Philippines yeah oh yeah you
know technically we were which you know
leads me to it really what I thought at
the time was quite a funny story we uh
it's in Utah at that time that you
couldn't get anything higher than a 3.2
beer but and you know you couldn't smoke
and unless you were older than 18 which
you get tickets for if they caught you
do they'd be in Salt Lake City police
but somehow we liberated some beer one
night and we had a guy in the dorm who
had a car so we went up to Canyon Road
that evening and we're drinking beer up
there next thing we know there's a cop
car by right behind us that cop gets us
all right you guys get out of the car
there was the three of us from the
Philippines and a friend of ours who was
dad was in the diplomatic corps so he
starts at one end it's a no were you
from Philippines sir next get
Philippines me Philippines and so he
comes in the last kid he says I suppose
you're from the Philippines two kids us
no sir I'm from Saudi Arabia
so they said you know guys if you go
back half mile up the road we don't go
that far so meanwhile we had dumped the
beer and everything so yeah that was
just that was the deal
it Salt Lake City and then at what point
did you start thinking I'm gonna go to
the Naval Academy instead of continuing
with your career at the University of
Utah my career at the University Utah
was fading fast she always say I had
joined in ROTC and really enjoyed that
but the rest of academics really you
know weren't my forte about
Christmastime
my parents were back in Newport Rhode
Island so I caught a train back to there
for Christmas and and that's when my dad
I had some serious talks about you know
what I was gonna do and I said well I
promised him I had to promise him that I
would apply to the Naval Academy and I
wasn't you know that keen on it but I
got to keep dad happy happy dad and he
kept that $50 a month spending money
coming which typically was spent long
before I'd arrived so I applied to the
Naval Academy took the SAT one weekend
and it did surprisingly well
and a couple of months later I get this
little envelope in the mail and I'm
thinking you know gosh
well actually was a packet I guess it's
table and I was thinking I was afraid to
open in my roommate say you know if it
was gonna be a rejection letter it's
probably just a simple letter he said
he'd get a packet they're probably gonna
you're probably in so sure enough I
opened it up I've been accepted
presidential appointments from JFK and
and it went off I am I had some
interesting experiences as an NROTC
kiddo at uni at Utah and one came from a
senior enlisted marine there was a Gunny
just an outstanding jet he he couldn't
do enough for you he organized the
little programs on the weekends where we
go out and set up ambushes in the
canyons up up from Salt Lake's there up
from the University of Utah and it
really is how you kind of I think that
that's where I got the idea that I
wanted
a marine from Gunny whose name I can't
remember but it was you know World War
two you guy I don't think so I think it
was more of a Korean guy okay you know
just outstanding he couldn't do enough
for you and he in my speech class to
give a a a speech that used a a prop and
so we had just had a class on the
Thompson submachine gun now you can't
imagine doing that you couldn't do this
today so I had hey Gunny can I brought
laptop from sub-machine yeah you know I
got a Tuesday from my speech class it'll
be gone for a couple of hours I head up
I had a guitar case from somebody on the
on my floor in the in the dorm that I
carry it in so I I'm carrying I'm
walking across campus with this guitar
case with a Thompson submachine ain't
got it didn't make a thing of it you
know
back then it's again this was sixty fall
of sixty two got to the speech class and
I said you know I kind of shut the class
up I'm here to talk about know my
whatever I don't forget what word I use
but I didn't my weapon here but my
device here in the case of course
everybody thought was gonna be guitar
pop that was Thompson submachine gun the
prof really keels over so I give him a
little spiel it was very well received I
must say I think I got an A for the
speech but he he gave me a pretty good
tongue lashing about bringing such a
thing to a classroom you know much more
ease to give you any other grade yeah no
probably not but you know it was fun so
uh when you when you how long was it
between when you got your acceptance
letter then when you actually showed up
for a bleep summer showed up for pleep
summer on June 26th of 1963 I probably
got my acceptance letter and March March
April something like that and were you
were you mentally prepared for plebe
summer I believe I was yes in fact I had
pretty much come to all stop active
academically at
when I got the acceptance letter because
they had had my first semester grades
and that was all they were going to
evaluate so I kind of ditched college
for the next four or five months there
was a joke I heard later in the and the
I wrote and then an ROTC unit was later
that the they joke that the way to get
in the Naval Academy was a flunk out of
the University of Utah but I did okay
there I struggle with academics at the
neighbor look at everybody looked at it
more as a leadership laboratory I guess
you know and then so so now it's 1963
you said you started started yeah are
you guys even thinking about Vietnam at
this point you know or not
I don't even recall you know hearing
about Vietnam at Utah that fall we had
you know heard and been not part of but
you know the whole deal have been about
the Cuban crisis that's that was all the
news that fall we followed that pretty
closely but now I don't think we had
heard about Vietnam at all yeah I think
I mean things were not really escalated
there at all you know so not at that
time
it's no surprise and you were in a I
mean you have some pretty notable people
in your in your Naval Academy class
well this is true I became friends early
on with a fella by then at that time
went by Larry Larry north and now it
goes by Ali I wanna one of my friends in
the class after that was Jim Webb he was
a boxer I was a boxer North was a boxer
a bunch of punch the guys I hung out
with boxers we had a felony Maurice
Smith who later on became a two-star
seal and I believe the first one to to
carry two stars I'm not sure about that
but a good guy captain of the track team
at Pete pace and the class first marine
to ever be chair of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff
four stars you know pretty pretty
heavy-duty company
yeah and then what about what about what
Staubach with you guys to stomach was in
the class of 65 it was two years ahead
of us but our plea beer the first year
there was the year he won the Heisman
Trophy which of course that argued well
for plebs because after a football game
if he won you'd have carry on that
weekend and if you beat army you got
carry on meaning you didn't have to
brace up in the halls and and you know
chop around in the halls
and you didn't have to sit on the last
couple of inches of your chair in the
mess and I know you got another guy that
have got some information on a a guy by
the name of tax Tech's Harkins fella
from Texas needless to say was my
roommate plebe summer and plebe year one
of several met him when I first came
into the room with a seed bag full of
gear that I know I had a stencil
he'd been there a couple of hours and
introduced himself is Maurice well I did
a double-take I don't think Maurice was
gonna fly I'm sure a couple hours later
when when I was worn out from hearing
about how great things were in Texas you
know he became text and text stuck he's
still text to this day good guy there's
some note about him trying to kill a
firsty man that wasn't text oh it was
North
I stopped North going into this first YZ
room early morning when we had when
window closing detail in the winter
you'd have to go and close the upper
class windows and he was headed off to
this first class room with a with a
bayonet bayonet and he was gonna do this
guy yet this guy was a horseshit beyond
belief you can't do that you'll be in
serious trouble buddy yeah you can't
kill someone you're gonna get instance
forever that's a good advice right there
Clee beer was a little different back
then I think
not quite the same anymore so you talked
about boxing and were you a boxer before
you showed up there
negative no no you just got into it when
I was not a particularly athletic young
man but boxing was something that most
of everybody started out from ground
zero with no experience so that's kind
of what I did
bleep summer and took it on a plebe year
and boxed plea beer some youngster year
which is sophomore year and same class
here junior year
first class year senior year I was in
academic trouble shall we say so yeah I
wasn't on the boxing team but I did run
the boxing sub squad where freshmen and
sophomores ended up if they fail boxing
as part of the PT curriculum you'd have
to go to a sub squad this was for every
sport until you could you know you just
subsequently tore the sub squad pass
just so you get a D because you couldn't
have an F did they make you I know guys
that I know that went to the Naval
Academy they made him box for a semester
they made him wrestle for a semester
they made him do judo for a semester do
they make you guys do wrestling and judo
we we did wrestling boxing we had some
part of the PT curriculum where it was
mandatory you had two years of boxing
lessons two years of wrestling two years
of gymnastics okay and four years of
swimming and they fit in all kinds of
one of the things of squash and golf and
track but yeah first two years you had
made some mandatory things that you had
to pass that's a part of the PT Creek
and didn't have judo hmm well it still
boxing and wrestling is a is an awesome
base to have as a fighter and then you
go in there oh yeah you're pretty good
to go yeah and then what I know you did
some cornering for some of the guys you
know and when they were boxing I did
that's my
a senior year first class year and North
was in the finals the boxing finals you
could win your Navy in your letter in
boxing even though it was a not an
intramural sport so much but it was a
more of a club sport but we didn't we
didn't box against other institutions
they do now there was all within the
brigade and we have champion we'd have
you know quarterfinals semifinals and
finals and I was in North's corner the
year he won his n boxing against another
well-known Naval Academy graduate Jim
Webb well I think you've had on your
program before and shall we say it was
interesting web web had a lot of
experience boxing he boxed Golden Gloves
I believe before he came to the Naval
Academy or at least city and county type
boxing state boxing from wherever it was
dis dad was stationed at the time but he
and north never they were two folks that
were butt heads I think their entire
careers and whenever they would run into
each other certainly at the Naval
Academy and certainly when they were
boxing but it was an interesting night
so this is a legit grudge match it but I
think that probably would be fair to say
it how'd it go down North won much to
everybody's surprise North was the was a
Street Fighter and the web was a more
polished boxer here yeah that's I mean
if you boxed if you boxed certainly at
the Golden Gloves level even not like
the county level you're you're a really
good that's what yeah yeah so that's
that's a that's a big achievement
well that somehow there's been you know
people who look backwards in it that
always comes up when you start talking
about North End or whip it was the
boxing match everybody knew it was a did
it distance it did the distance being
only three rounds you know back then
yeah bar there two hundred rounds of
three-minute rounds because sometimes
they have amateurs box turning around
I think there were two minute rounds so
six minutes of your latte and I know the
rest like kind of wiped you out and you
know five six minutes but we were we
were spent when you know at the end of a
boxing match either spent because all
you could do to just pull yourself out
of it out of the ring and what did you
wet like for boxing for use as you were
new to boxing and you weren't much of an
athlete before what do you think you
took away from boxing well don't quit I
mean I went to the semifinals my junior
year got knocked out of the ring by that
guy my opponent got back up got back in
the ring
took the standing eight-count and
finished the fight and I know I met a
Marine officer a year later when I was
you know on service election-night
was able to select the Marine Corps and
he said gutsiest thing I've ever stayed
well thank you sir but in honor you
don't quit it ain't over until it's over
and it was over that night for me but
you mentioned from the Gunny that you
worked with that the University of Utah
that you were thinking Marine Corps when
you showed up at the Naval Academy or
was that was that that did you stick
with that the whole time I did you know
my dad being career Navy I knew I would
I could never fill his footsteps and
heeds it he was perplexed why we want to
go Marine Corps he asked me straight out
one time I think was a first year a
senior said ma what is it that the
Marine Corps second lieutenant has that
a navy instant doesn't have you know
they got three hot meals a day a nice
bed with sheets to sleep in so what is
it Marine Corps single tenant got that a
Navy incident doesn't have I looked at
him I said yeah I think it's respect and
the old man down
Wow yeah that's that's definitely that's
definitely shots fired for sure and my
grandpa was not somebody you probably
want to say that to all the time though
well he was not the nicest guy he just
was sir like I said a little to the
right of Attila the Hun and there was a
couple of ways to do things there was
his way and there was everybody else's
he he took me out for a dinner before I
you know got on the train to head off
from the Naval Academy for him up from
Providence Rhode Island where I could
catch the train back then and he said he
told me he said Bobby you graduate from
the Naval Academy and I'll buy you the
car of your choice oh thank you Dad
four years later I'm getting close to
graduation I said dad you remember when
I when I when I when I left for the
Naval Academy just told me you buy him
with a car my choice if I graduate he
looked at me said did you get it in
writing know it as you as the other
thing that's on the folding is it's in
1963 when you show up there hey I'm
gonna be a Marine
but you there's no war going on now we
fast forward it's 19 well 1967 you know
and Vietnam is now I mean Vietnam really
started to escalate in like 1965 1966
even more in 1967 I mean you guys now
know in the Marine Corps what you're
signing up for there's no mystery oh no
no no we know precisely what we were
signing up for there was a board I think
this has been referenced in other places
and books and articles aboard of you
know those who've gone before us those
have died and it was starting to fill up
with you know pictures and names from
Vietnam so yeah we understood that but
you know having I'm sure been come at
yourself that as you know you it's not
gonna happen to you yeah maybe the guy
on the left or the right but not to
you're bulletproof this in your own mind
and so you know you're worried about
maybe getting maimed I don't think we've
been worried about that you worried
about possibly getting killed but then
hey there's nothing that for that you
know your your worries are done and and
then your family picks up on it or you
thought you might get a little you know
flea flicker flicker flicker or wound or
something like that and get a Purple
Heart but you never figured you know you
might come back without limbs or
otherwise you know markedly impaired
that just never entered your mind I'm
sure if it did you would have been
useless to your unit the the guys that
are all all going for the marine option
at the academy its competitive right
it's like it's hard to get that brick is
it hard to get that marine option coming
out of the Academy oh well I'm not I
can't speak for today because today
they'll have like 250 you know guys and
gals go in the Marine Corps in my day
and in the years in the 60s and before
there was a certain percentage of a
class that could go Marine Corps we had
some just about 900 guys in my class and
we had 86 slots and they were divided in
half from the that took half from the
upper half of the class grade wise on
half of the lower so you could get in
the Marine Corps saying being the middle
of the lower half of your class when a
fellow who was in the lower part of the
upper half of his class wouldn't have
got selected because those you know 43
slots were gone
and I got slapped 86 when I went down
for service election night I was
sweating bullets but what I got it in
fact that a good friend of mine it was a
couple of numbers behind me offered me
two grand for my spot if I would give it
up and so cuz he wanted to oh my god I
knew how much he wanted to go to Marine
Corps I said you know I can't do that
either you know that he I know that but
they it was competitive in that respect
it was you know academics played a lot a
big part in it
yeah the Marine Corps does that
with the way they give your jobs in the
Marine Corps to like coming out of the
basic school I know like they take like
the class would break it up into thirds
and like the first you pick your job so
he could be the number one guy and you
might you already you if you keep the
number one guy you can get your job but
you might be the top of the next third
down and you get your selection then the
top of the last third and you get your
selection so it's a it's it's a way that
they distribute the people so that not
every single the the top of the class
goes everyone's goes infantry and the
whatever job it's at the bottom we get a
bunch of people that weren't the highest
performers right exactly the Marine
Corps smart it's about the Marine Corps
of the Marine Corps Marine Corps
understands that it's about the Marine
Corps because they haven't lasted this
long without being able to put up a good
fight both you know in a nation's Wars
and back in the DC area when the time
comes along for keeping the Marine Corps
the Marine Corps and now as is your dad
talking you anymore about looking at you
and saying hey son there's a war going
on and he's you know obviously being in
the Navy in a world war two he knows
exactly what the Marine Corps does and
he's is he having many more talks to you
and saying hey you might want to think
about this a little bit more no not a
one you know he kind of respected my
decision I guess and just you know let
me go at it like I say is an interesting
person I got back to Bethesda after I
was shot spent 12 months in Bethesda he
came to see me once which for him was
probably enough and actually for me it
was enough you know but I you know I
later on found out that you know he
obviously was affected you know by about
my being moved I kind of joked at him
one day one day we were out you know
barbecuing some hot dogs or something
and I said dad Jim was collected on my
life insurance what are you talking
about Bobby this is one day you almost
got that tensor ten grand
you know servicemen is a group life
insurance from from from my demise of
Vietnam don't talk like that that was it
that's it that's that's the affection
you got absolutely that was the yeah
that was they understood me
and the compassion that I got from bit
so you get done with you get done with
your Naval Academy you graduate and now
you're going to the basic school right
right
do you remember what rank you are at the
academy look how close to the bottom oh
I think I was a since on server
selection night went down in groups of
50 which is why I was sweating we
getting a place in the Marine Corps
because you know they could have all
been gone by the time I got down there
in the last group of 50 because I was in
the last group of 50
answers that question you weren't
anchorman so you didn't know I was like
oh mama I didn't get the dollar from
everybody but oh is that what the last
time was that's right right right you
know I've never confirmed but the last
person in the class gets a dollar from
from every blessing well so you can walk
off with you know six seven eight nine
hundred bucks
the this spot of distinction I guess or
or not well we're still graduated so I
guess at that point it doesn't matter
and you got paid unlike my class we were
kind of put out by coz our anchorman was
a foreign national I think from a
country that didn't even have a navy so
we were like don't even wanna [__] over
this book maryska and of course we did
because that was just that's a tradition
it's always been that way
so uh you show up at TBS and now it's
you know I know graduated in June of
June seventh of 67 and I put in for the
first basic school class that was
forming which is a first of July that
was that the beginning of the fiscal
year
back then July 1st so you know I had a
few weeks at home boom right back down
to the Quantico to start the basic
school okay so you started in this
summer
sometimes I'm 67 right and then what how
well did the Naval Academy prepare you
for the basic school I think pretty well
of course we didn't ever get into the
tactical side of things at the Naval
Academy for
for the Marine Corps but you know you
were in good shape you obviously could
wear your uniform whichever it was a
Marine Corps Navy bit of a well because
you've been doing it for the past four
years and I had gone to jump school
between my summer leave between junior
and senior year and I the physical
requirements for that we're pretty
demanding you know we've got data Fort
Benning in August after cruise and Maine
that baby is hot that red clay in
Georgia
reflects that heat and you sweat I saw
those Midshipmen coming and of course
you know we were we we'd be running
around with navy chairs and any cadre
fellow you know staff sergeants I could
pop up and you know halt us and drop us
for push-ups and everything which we
loved I don't think there were any UDT
or sealed groups going through when we
went through but they just ate the
program up you know yeah needless to say
yeah I went I was one of the eventually
seals stopped going to Airborne School
at Fort Benning Georgia and started
running it in-house okay but yeah I was
lucky enough to go to Airborne School
and and yes the the instructors down
there definitely appreciated our
presence of those no yeah certainly did
it's ridiculous to because we're coming
out of you know buds right literally a
week or whatever you know we travel
cross-country we show up there so we're
in really good shape so there was really
nothing that they could do to us exactly
hurt us and we just would and of course
that encouraged guys to be you know wise
asses and you know why would it make you
do pushups you can't make me you enough
push-ups so is that that whole thing
going and and now now that you're a TBS
though well now you know exactly what's
gonna happen you know you're gonna go to
Vietnam right regardless of your MOS
that you came out with of course I want
to be a no.3 and most of my friends did
too
oh yeah that's a good point so it's not
actually guaranteed so I'm thinking you
still have to do a service selection
inside or like thinks I drink exactly
exactly you put in for your top three
and and you hope you get number one of
course and and the most guys did
you're pretty savvy about your
capabilities and your you know likes and
dislikes by the time
you get 2 tbs I think regardless of
where you come from you know we had a
lot of recent ROTC grads some recent OCS
grads and enabled academy grads and you
couldn't distinguish who came from what
pipeline you know they're all pretty
motivated folks back then and I'm sure
all the instructors must have been guys
that were coming off of towards they
were just back from their tours beyond
time and they were all captains or above
yeah very sharp guys they didn't didn't
pick a slacker soon enough to be his
instructors at TBS and how I mean
compared to the Naval Academy was it
just a totally different vibe of
seriousness because they know what
exactly what their prepare you guys for
it sure was you know you're here out on
problems day time problems nighttime
problems didn't matter when they ended
and if you got back and turned in any
gear you checked out 3 a.m. in the
morning you're still up you know at Oh
dark thirty the next morning no you
didn't do that the Naval Academy you
know your head study hour and stuff like
that but now there was a definitely
heightened level of serious seriousness
at the basic school again all the
instructors were giving you straight
poop you know because they had just come
back from there or recently back my
platoon commander we have a platoon of
about 50 guys it was a captain to Silver
Stars you know well decorated big guy
you know they don't take again it Marine
Corps looks that you all kinds of ways
they look at how you did a basic school
your height versus versus your weight
some other foul obviously other factors
before they assign you someplace like if
you're if you think you want to get two
to eight and I and be part of that in
Washington DC you know you've got to be
like six feet or higher and taller or
whatever cuz you know they're sending
the cream with the cream of their crap
because you're you know you're
representing a United States Marine
Corps in front of the public on a
regular basis and rightfully so all the
services do that you know that the
guards at Arlington
or you know four feet eight and sloppy
you know they're all standing tall and
looking good and very professional
needless to say how hard was it to you
know when you when you started picking a
job obviously you said you wanted to be
an infantry infantry platoon commander
and how much competition was there for
that what did you have guys that were
like oh I'm not doing that I'm not doing
that job you can have it was there was a
competition for it it was only competent
there we didn't feel competition you
know obviously had to do well on the old
course and all the different evolutions
and he had to pass the PRT and you know
you had to do well and land navigation
daytime nighttime do well on the rifle
range of pistol range but that was that
was just part of the competition of TBS
you were always competing with your
métier what do you call your classmates
classmate yeah your classmates at TBS
but you know a lot of guys wanted to go
infantry and obviously not everybody was
gonna go infantry I don't know what the
selection process was but I had a good
friends were unable Academy not really a
good friend but he he was he was one guy
that would go I say are you gonna go in
four three two also meaning also and of
course you had no idea yeah it depends
on what the Marine Corps what their
selection process was and whether you
made or not and he ended up not getting
infantry which was probably probably a
good move for him and the Corps is there
any is there anything that you had to
struggles with when you're going through
the basic school other than maybe you
know the old course or something like
that but I was just that you know a
eight-minute struggle and as long as you
were doing the best the best you could
you know that they didn't beat you up to
higher or mark you down but no I didn't
really feel there was anything that was
gonna hold me back and their training
you with all the tactics small unit
tactics naval gunfire calling for fire
all
there are you feeling like you were you
feeling like you were getting good
preparation for the battlefield I did
what that what the base of school does
is it teach you everything you need to
know as a company level officer you know
from your time as a second lieutenant up
to to captain after that there's an
another school there's I'm not sure what
it's called but you know for for senior
captains and new majors but yeah I felt
well prepared they had a Vietnam village
built up in Quantico staff of course by
Vietnamese and you know you practice
that you know you did hilla copter
operations you did you know walking
insertions you didn't land navigation
daytime and night
which I'm sure you know it's a different
horse of a different color he's indeed
yeah but he was apparently was pretty
proficient a graduate 7th in the class
not first like Webb did in his class but
that's that's ok 7 was good enough
letter accommodation coming out of the
basic school and that's 7 out of class
how many had about two hundred four
years okay no so it seems like you were
better at the field craft than you were
at the academia well this is true in
fact in fact it you know I got shot in
the head and I have classmates who said
who still say to this day yeah we think
that made you smarter yeah because I did
go on to graduate school and get a
masters and a PhD yeah you know after I
was retired out of the Marine Corps and
and maybe there's something to that I
don't know so then yeah so the basic
school is what six months long about
five and a half then yeah they're
shorten it up five and a half months
long you get done with the basic school
you get infantry right and then what
happens I got selected for
reconnaissance replacement training
which was a couple of weeks in Southern
California we get Pendleton again from
more supporting arms training in
artillery that sort of thing there and
then a week at Coronado
are learning about a naval gunfire
support did you use the the board was
they call that the smoke board did they
have the little fake terrain set up that
you could call for fire on I went to the
I went to the Marine Corps naval gunfire
school and they had this terrain board
and it was kind of like a it must have
been built in like 1975 and you'd call
for fire if you got in the right spot
little smoke would come up through that
spot it was like you were looking at you
know through binoculars somewhere it was
pretty good no I never had never saw
anything like that only where we were
actually filing firing a real live
artillery at Belton and at the naval
gunfire support school we had this big
board but it was it was blue you know it
was the ships that in the ocean per se
but that was interesting because I did
one a night get to fire the cruiser
Providence in Vietnam which was which
was fun you know they could they
couldn't use their six inch guns because
they're too flat so use their five inch
you know bringing in direct fire on we
had a bunch of lights below us I think
folks were trying to move move their
troops around another night but and we
you know what this this was on call for
so we used it so you got to use the
naval gunfire I did like a dream of mine
ever since i sat there on that little
training boy it was a dream boxer and
then I got to use my Bravo Zulu term at
the end of it I confer they're almost
the real robbery I was ooh yeah that is
outstanding
that is outstanding I've never even I
never even got close to even remotely
thinking about calling for day with a
fire for real so I probably worked too
close to you know big waterways yeah
yeah and I don't know there's always
that thing where guys want a fire you
know a bunch of different weapons
treating combat right and I had one guy
get shot in the chest but it hit him in
the chest plate so yeah I wasn't with
him but they actually had video that's
he gets shot in the chest plate and so
he's all mad
he's mad and he shoots a bunch of
machine-gun rounds and and someone goes
hey shoot your pistol and - he goes he
looks at it but why he says what would
make you feel better so he ball system
out and shoots that - but and I'm sure
if you would have had a naval gunfire
who knows maybe he would have maybe he
would have gone for it I don't know
about the pistol you know when we fired
the 45 for qualification down on the TBS
I think our instructor actually told us
you know in combat if this is all you've
got you know you're probably just better
off throwing the pistol atom and
shooting at them because you have a
better chance of hitting it the bad guy
on the other end did you guys not have
inventory officer course back then cuz
that's like a you know multi-month
course now after TBS we did not know you
or you're considered good to go you know
after graduation on TBS yeah I know now
they have a ten-week officer or infantry
officer training course which I think
would be I've been outstanding but we
had what we had so so uh you go to this
you go to this recon course mm-hmm and
so now you get are you getting jump jump
pay and all that stuff now no you know
even though let's jump qualified if
you're if you're not in a unit that
maintains your jump qualification in the
Corps you don't get jump a in fact we've
got to Vietnam and first recon battalion
there was only one company you know
there that maintain their jump status
that was Charlie Company and they were
the Force Recon company they did the
same thing as the battalion Recon
companies did but they did maintain
their jump status that's all they got
jump a and every extra 75 bucks a month
which is a big deal back then so you end
up you end up going through this recon
training and then what happens in its
time is it time to deploy - you know
it's time to get on a bus and head up to
Air Force Base in San Bernardino don't
know the name of it
the flood or flue order at Okinawa spend
a week there so that kind of trip would
dribble you in are you with are you with
all different branches of servicemen are
you just with Marines at this point just
with just with Marines at this point you
know going over flew on Saturn Airlines
I believe you know a non-scheduled
non-skid airline total canal oh just
like civilian was there civilian
what do they call hostesses stewardesses
on stewardesses oh yeah yeah yeah
a few stews by defendants but typically
you wouldn't have anything to do in
Okinawa while you waited for your for
your assignment to be flown into country
but when I got to look at when we got to
Okinawa there was about five of us that
were travelling together we had been at
the Recon replacement training together
and we were just milling around the
receiving area after we got off the the
plane and somehow I got up above oh
somehow it's a higher up than the crowd
below me and I'm watching it and there's
this young Lance Corporal with a
clipboard he's going to each of the
second tenets that I had you know my
buddies and asked him some question and
they're going No so I said I said this
poor kid yeah I've been in this position
before huh I'll find out what's going on
so he didn't he but he needed his is a
company Gunny or something had sent him
down he needed a signature from an
officer to run three plane loads of
Marines through a little program on an
Okinawa where they your fam fired the
m16 because never I know none of us had
ever seen an m16 muscle s fired one
before we went into Vietnam I say it fam
fire familiar race fight from my
familiarize yourself fire the m16 before
you went in country made sure all your
shots were up-to-date and all your
paperwork was up-to-date so I said sure
you know so I signed for him I'd have to
get up every night every other night
while I was there for about a week meet
a incoming plane about 2 a.m. in the
morning find the senior enlisted guy on
the plane form these guys up take him
over to a barracks how to draw a
mattress you know flop down it's on the
beat you know how to be out next morning
at 7:30 in the morning go to chow then
we start him through the little of a
program that you had to go through
before he could get in country so I'd
met my three planes a little more than a
week's time I was definitely afraid my
officer buddies we're gonna rotate into
country before I did didn't happen we
all went off together but there's an
interesting leak would you shoot in the
basics Cory I'm 14 and 14 you know now
how do you feel about the m16 when you
got it I loved it lightweight and a most
lightweight
unfortunately most Marines in Vietnam
found out that I had pitted barrels and
sure enough I had a trade mine and you
know what the two after I got there with
one one that was a newer one with a good
barrel and that's crazy you guys didn't
even get get even shoot that weapon
don't say you got that Okinawa what's
right and then was the other training
course that are giving you like basic
like preparation for Vietnam jungle
navigation or something like that or in
Okinawa you know you were just you were
just kind of on your own until you
rotate it in Khe Sanh was getting hot
then still ISTA we used to go to some
three Shack Operations Shack of some
outfit on Okinawa and hear the morning
brief about Khe Sanh and kind of look at
each other anything you don't want to
get sent there no no no so then you
spend that so you spend that one is a
week in Okinawa about yeah I know you
guys all fly over to Vietnam right right
where do you find two dan egg and then
when you get there what's that process
like that for us we get there in the
evening it's dark again
somebody met your yo took you off
somewhere you grabbed a mattress flopped
it down in some barracks at the end of
the runway and you slept until next
morning with all this F worse take it
off above you know sleep did you have
that stereotypical moment that people
talk about which is you know the guys
that are going home the guys that are
rotating at home after their year and
you see
at the contrast between the the new guys
showing up with their brand-new gear and
the old guys that are heading home and
they look like they've been through hell
and back no never saw anybody that was
going home you know down at the Nang Air
Field you know didn't didn't see him we
arrive sometime in the mill the night
and it was dark and we had no yeah you
know you have that little kind of
internal feeling of impending doom or
dread or something I don't know what it
was maybe was just your adrenaline
pumping you know that you're finally
gonna get in country and you know what
what's gonna you know you're gonna take
incoming rounds while you're landing no
there's no yeah it's a normal landing
you get off to get off the aircraft or
you know somebody meets its officers
this way I listen to guys that way you
know drew your mattress try to sleep for
the rest tonight do you know where
you're heading at this point you knew
the division you were going to first or
third third was up north in North I
Corps first was down around around at an
Ag and you know I was going to the first
division you didn't even know if you're
gonna get to the recon battalion you
went to division the next day we went to
division we got introduced with
commanding general for some reason and
we were required to sit down you gave us
a big book rules of engagement you had
to read that sign that you'd read it and
understood and then you got sent off to
to a two-year unit and but three of us
were lucky enough to go to the
reconnaissance battalion the other two
they went off to regular grunt units
infantry units so when you get your
assigned to recon and then what do you
do you guys drive up there do you take a
helicopter up there how you get up to
your actual unit the actual unit 1st
recon battalion was located just below
and across the street from Division
Headquarters he said yeah you'll walk
down there and as I said before we had
the one cup one company Charlie Company
it wasn't with the battalion in denying
it was forward based at feu by they're
the ones that kept up their jumps
at us and one of my buds who had gone
through the Recon replacement training I
was slated to go up there because I was
single up to the force reconnaissance
company and he asked if I would mind
giving that position to him if it was
okay with the colonel because he was
married and expecting their first kid oh
I needed that extra 75 bucks I was just
happy to be there
I said sure take it if that's what you
want yeah that's no big deal
yeah so he went up to he went up to the
force company and fooled by I stayed
there with a battalion and Danang and
there was the you know what was checking
in like I mean you're showing up there
your new guy these guys been in country
and this is something that it always
surprised me about Vietnam is that you
guys would rotate well just one
individual individual right placements
right whereas for me all my deployments
were unit yes whole unit is going in and
the whole right sleeve and and so that's
got to be it's got to be a weird thing
showing up as a new guy and there's a
bunch of people that have been there for
between I guess between two days and 360
whatever days right your hair I mean my
my working premise when I got to Vietnam
was that anybody who was there a day
longer than Iowa then I had been there
was a day smarter but the situation or
day more experience and by god I was
going to listen to this person you know
but interesting enough my platoon wasn't
even there they were aboard ship with
the afloat battalion and we're in car
always kept a battalion float off the
coast of Vietnam it could jump into an
operation you know at a moment's notice
give or take and they always had a
reconnaissance platoon with them and
they apparently used them pretty much as
point for the battalion so that was not
a plum job but my my platoon was its
outgoing platoon commander it was a Bork
ship so I didn't see them for two weeks
I just I had nothing to do except I got
tasks to sit on court-martials and you
know I had the unit grades quarterly
grades or something something like that
would do I had to go home
guys service record books and give them
a grade for their performance over the
last quarter without annoying and
without have her having seen them you
know you this was gonna be used for
promotions so I did the best I could you
know I took in service record book how
long the guy had been the Corps in
country I been wounded what was a level
of education you know I signed a few
points and then you know like one to ten
and then I added everybody points up and
I had agreed to give him and recommended
the top three for promotion or something
like that it was crazy but I had to do
it switch what you did we were just
complementing the brilliance of the
Marine Corps I mean you gotta tell a
story like that then okay so then did
you eventually get flown out to the ship
to be with them or did they no they came
back they rotated rotated back they are
just filthy dirty I think that came
right from the bush and the lieutenant I
got to talk to for about ten minutes
because he was like overdue to rotate
out of country so he just he just wanted
to get a shower you know a uniform and
get back down at an and what I uh what
pearls of wisdom did he give you in
those ten minutes he he told me a who
the who the best guys in the platoon
were and who I think he thought I might
want to keep my eye on and that was
about it
no no tactical and I saw no exact
Achilles on anything that's interested
you know I always say that leadership is
the most important thing and what he was
trying to give you as a heads up on
who's like who's the best guys and from
a leadership perspective that's
interesting he just wanted out but but I
was in a hooch yeah you know with with
other lieutenants second first offense
who's been there you know anywhere for
him maybe two months to four months and
they were filling me in on
I don't have play operate how the deal
operated was there anything that
surprised you that you were her and
hearing from those guys anything that
you know you said oh I didn't really
expect that the only thing that really
surprised me I think once once I got
into recon and got working with him was
that occasionally you had to go out far
enough that you weren't under anybody's
artillery fan you know you weren't on
rarely where we were under the 105 fan
and the one five five fan usually and
then there was army 175 which were very
scary thanks because I the word was this
they could click on a they could you
know bump out a click when it when they
fire these things they were big we flew
over him
one time when I looked at him I swear
they drooped you know 175 artillery face
they were huge i swirly drooped and then
of course if you were out past the 175
fan you had nothing but air to call on
and that losses took about 20 minutes to
get there and pilots never really
trusted ground officers to you know to
bring them in correctly so they'd always
want to fly out an aerial observer you
know a lot of these little spit get
planes you know caller in the back and I
don't know what they were Oh V tens I
think but that was kind of surprising
this but our killer over there was
fantastic great but you know they were
on call 24/7 obviously best thing I ever
fired was Marine Corps self-propelled
eight-inch there like it looked like a
big tank with a eight inch you know
fired an eight inch shell when they were
accurate to the nth degree
unbelievable but basically artillery was
excellent over saved our bacon many a
time
when you it's been two weeks your your
guys get back you take over splatoon
commander right what's your intro
meeting with the guys in the platoon
what do you say to just kind of
introduce myself probably told him the
same thing that I stole you if you've
been here one day long and I have and
you got a better idea
or everything you do talk to me you know
I'm here to listen you know I want you
all to get back home obviously you know
intact and not tacked in as we used to
say in fact the five and a half months I
was a platoon commander we only took one
serious casualty and that was me and I
wouldn't have it any other way we were
extremely lucky but we were also pretty
good you know we didn't do dumb things
there were folks who would like harbour
at night near a trail and hope bad guys
would come down it just so they could
try to set up a hasty ambush no no no
once once your troops knew that you were
serious about their welfare we've done
anything for you and of course you'd do
anything for them I had 25 23 Marines of
my platoon made me call a corpsman they
rotated in and out according to the will
of the Italian aid station the finest
young men ever cell unassembled I know
most potent commanders say the same
thing but this kids were average age in
19 hours education ninth grade you know
but they were taught they were primo if
I'd have told him that we've been tasked
to flap in Hanoi drop in with a river
raft and paddle up and free the folks
out of the Hilton they would if they
were they'd have been right there maybe
there were just great kids what was that
was kind of normal
well first of all was your first
operation they went on with these guys
well first thing that I did was turned
out to be a
Tet 1968 broke on my first snap-in
patrol I was they tried to get you on a
snap-in patrol or two before you started
leading your guy so you know you were
just you know you're just there is to
observe and learn
and your patrol leader might be in III
in my case it was an e5 sergeant e5 and
we got up this Ridgeline and after
crossing this path it looked like the
i-5 of people paths and we got now it
was smooth and we got up into a bad
bunch of brush and some rocks and we
were looking up the ridge line your
Center for four NVA come cooling down
down this Highway so four and then there
were eight
then there were 16 32 cities your first
mission is the first
yes exactly is this your platoon no I
was with long yeah and the leader the
platoon leaders need five well yeah the
petrolia was an e-flat role he was an e5
right young man great gang man and so
his rule of thumb was where there's four
there's more because I only saw these
four guys come out of the jungle down
this Ridgeline first let's go set up an
ambush
no sergeant no no no where there's four
there's no we stopped counting at 400
and by now we had artillery coming in we
had air on the way we had a aerial
observer up there
we fired artillery all day all afternoon
into the night into the evening we have
Puff the Magic Dragon dropping flares
with with the Jets coming in underneath
it we could drop a napalm at night oh it
was unbelievable and this is your first
night what are you doing the call for
fire no no it's urgent my stars do it
yeah you know I was I was there to learn
and to the pucker factor was like this
yeah guys would go on that one or two
snap-in patrols and never see anything
but and this they might come to Vietnam
yeah and they maybe have a little too
laissez-faire attitude but this was my
welcome to Vietnam and I thought it was
great
I mean we were dropping our tour around
these guys they're running down the path
toward our position you know and they
were they were in the brush they're not
on the path but they're in the brush we
had brush we had rocks on
like our north side and our east side
and West Side East Side and south side
Weston North Lee has had brush and
there's you know North Vietnamese are
there in the brush coming toward us
they're crying and they're screaming you
know yelling for mom whatever whatever
you do and that's your North Vietnamese
soldier and they when they bring a run
right into us so start brings in
artillery behind us real close you know
Danger Close so we got shrapnel flying
over our heads
and of course this this dissuades these
bad guys from coming toward us also had
a kid set up when he should have been a
laying flat like a Mushu pancake took a
piece of shrapnel right in his face and
knocked out a few teeth and cut open his
lip in the room and the shrapnel is
dropping down it burned right through
your through your utility shirt burn
your skin you just you just endured it
it was a hairy so Danger Close rounds
coming your first night out at Vietnam
well welcome to the war thank you guys
and you guys maintained your your
clandestine they're still alive oh yeah
how many guys were out there with you ah
probably about ten eleven that was a
heavy Patrol yeah all right so now at
how many of those snapping patrols did
you do to what was the next one
light-second well next one was wasn't
even wasn't that interesting from a
tactical point of view but it was gonna
be a led by a lieutenant who had got a
little tanked up at the O club the night
before I hadn't given the patrol
patroller so we're down there waiting
for on the LZ away before the insert
hilla coppers to get ready to take us
off come down the hill was the battalion
commander Lieutenant Colonel he comes
over to our patrol points to the
lieutenant sir Pat get back up pack of
year you're going to the grunts you know
boom he was
colonel system against Lance Corporal
system controller I think you guys can
run some trouble yes sir no problem so
we did it was great but [__] can this
guy sits right there on the spot and you
could do that in recon I had to do it
once to one of my guys what'd the guy do
that rated you fired him on the spot
I had my patrol was like cut in half I
led my platoon was cut in half I let
half of it you know anywhere from eight
to ten guys depending on who was not on
our and our who wasn't sick that sort of
thing and my two I have to start ie6
Staff Sergeant here and the other Pathan
we flip-flop about about halfway through
my tour when I was about five five and a
half months ago and so you know my the
guys I led we were our code name was
West arch we had an excellent reputation
of attire they were fast day like they
felt like they were kind of distant
cousins in the platoon but I know I got
okay about pep talk that night with with
perform at the patrol order so you know
you guys are guys are just like west are
no different and you know again 9th
grade education same age you know same
skills and so I went to my little spiel
and you know you know my reputation I'm
done commander
you know administrative leave your stuff
unit you know how I operate anybody
doesn't want to go go a fast day now one
kid raises his hand okay you don't have
to go pack your gear get out of here
don't you're not sleeping tonight with
these guys you know and I don't know
whatever happened it was I never came
back from that Patrol you know but I'm
sure it was taken care of so when you
start getting into what was the kind of
typical mission that you guys were doing
typical mission was you know we'd go out
on a six seven day patrol we just were
just snooping and pooping that's what we
called it
finding a trails that the enemy would
use race campus would you guys answer on
helicopter would you guys just foot
patrol no always hillock upper yeah it's
always here pick out a spot and and get
dropped off and then what was your word
your SOPs once you guys got inserted we
got up we start hopefully it was where
the the insert LZ was where you know the
Operations Officer her the operations
Shack
said it was sometimes it wasn't there
but you know that's why you know as a
patrolling I did it when I got in the
helicopter was dump my gear get out my
little map mmm and insert myself between
the pilot and a co-pilot because if you
didn't know where you were when you
started the patrol you aren't gonna know
where you were for the next six seven
days where'd you guys insert in a
daytime in the nighttime it pre-dawn in
the dusk when would you guys go in wait
going in daytime we'd be down to Elsie
waiting by about 8 o'clock in the
morning birds would come in if they
weren't being used for medevacs and
stuff for some operation that was going
on about mid-morning they do up and get
a brief from the intelligence folks at
first recon we'd be sitting around there
and then they come back down from their
brief we'd pop on the aircraft and it's
off we go so like midday you're getting
miss day yeah that was pretty much
probably generally he hit the and then
what you hit the ground and what would
you guys do as soon as you hit the
ground what was your what was your
standard operating procedure so pay with
the DD and get out of that LZ fast yeah
nothing says rains are coming in here
then a bunch of helicopters come into
landed we have two two Huey's now we'd
be on a 240 sixes oh okay you know yeah
army had Huey's you know transport
troops Marine Corps did anytime in a
Marine Corps they probably about sixty
helicopters in Vietnam on any given day
about half of them would be air worthy
so we had Huey gunships Huey's I guess
carry the brass around but then we
didn't use much troop transporting all
so big old 40s all noisy 46s I did would
you guys just like we always used to do
something which was sit look and listen
so like we would you know go two or
three hundred yards away from the LZ and
then we'd all just stop up and just
let's get them yeah yeah pretty much the
same way yeah
and then would you guys have different
areas where you were headed to
specifically we did we had a patrol
route that was pre-planned and an
extract point that was pre-planned now
and froze rarely went you know according
to the pre-planning which the the you
know the operations Shack did you know
we didn't do that we're actually telling
you where where yeah where we're gonna
go in at but they have a recommended
patrol route which we'd stick to if we
could couldn't all the time and then we
get out at this point where they had
recommended yeah again sometimes it
would work sometimes it wouldn't what
was it before how often would you guys
be contacted by the enemy you know it
wasn't all that frequently because I you
know we did we were good we were snooped
at poop with your purpose of being there
was to not right you know in recon your
job wasn't to you know find them fix
them and Foxtrot them yeah you didn't
get online with 9 or 10 guys or 11 maybe
and say charge you know your idea was to
gather information but if if the
situation was to your advantage
you could you could you know if if the
leader felt that it was worth the effort
set up an ambush but normally would
bring artillery on if we saw groups and
I probably ran 21 patrols and I'd say
probably good three quarters of a weed
we don't we had fire missions on top of
bad guys well that's that's I presented
well there's one other thing like I
think what you go through
what do you were in Ramadi brother but
there was there were some of my guys in
Ramadi that
would get contacted a lot there was one
one group over in Eastern Ramadi and
they did I was I was actually briefing a
I was briefing the CG sort of commander
who's the colonel that was in charge of
all Special Operations and I said you
know sir the Mike my group that served
you know six seals that are over in
eastern Ramadi I said they've been
they've been in enemy contact 23
straight operations and I'm lucky and I
didn't plan this for dramatic effect but
my Intel officer who's running the
Tactical Operations Center comes walking
in and says hey sir just just want to
let you know that the guys out east are
in contact right now and I looked at the
colonel I said make that 24 missions in
a row but there was definitely some some
hot hot areas yeah it was pretty much
expected if you were going out in Ramadi
that you were gonna get in contact by
the enemy and I don't know what the
percentage was but it was it was a vast
more it was very rare that my guys would
come back and had a head and shot their
guns man you know very rare yeah but but
75 but I also what was interesting when
I came home from that deployment and
would talk to some of the Vietnam guys
depending on the platoon depending on
the seal platoon in Vietnam there's guys
that shot their weapons on a six-month
deployment shot their weapons three
times four times and there's other
platoons in Vietnam with a shelter to
drop their weapons a hundred extra ten
so it all depended on and my first
deployment to Iraq I think I shot my gun
we got like four or five firefights so
really not not that big of a deal and
then in Ramadi I don't did that numbers
the numbers just very high for as far as
the whole task unit getting into getting
into big gun fights but three quarters
of the time you know that's that's a lot
of fire missions well but yeah but they
weren't gun fights per se you know
they'd be you eyeballing somebody or
some place or some trail crossing or
some little village you might come
across in the middle of nowhere
one time we came across out a cornfield
in the middle of jungle I mean it was it
wasn't jungle per se because there was
no high tree canopy over it was just a
feel a clearing in the
of the jungle with rows of corn eyes but
this is not your typical jungle plant
uh-huh so we'd get a little higher
ground we'd watch to see if and we come
no came in there and settle down there's
no a few hooches there - whereabouts
were you guys operating in Vietnam we
are operating north south and west of
Danang first reconnaissance battalions
mission was to - to patrol the rocket
belt around the airport a Danang but
that wasn't particularly that far out so
we didn't a lot further out looking for
you know main main line NVA forces and
or where they where they camped out the
trails they used etc etc but gunfights
were relatively rare which is a good
thing because you can't see anybody in
the jungle anyway you're typically just
firing blind so that was one of the nice
things about the m16 it would put out a
lot of fire for you and that's what you
needed over there you know you didn't
need a heavy bullet necessarily to to
knock guys down but the 7.62 or 5 point
whatever was just fine my what a 7.62
that's the big heavy that's the import
yeah when you were when you would get
these mission taskings kind of from
above above from the from the battalion
right we think they'd give it to you
that how long with the planning cycle
take for you guys to come up with a plan
and do your briefing and all that about
24 hours wasn't it wasn't hardcore
boilerplate like nowhere near the detail
that I know that you all went through in
Ramadi but you know it was just you we
were out six seven days back two or
three so that was a regular schedule you
you knew I mean the kids were already
the Marines were already you know their
weapons were clean if we had done things
that we needed to do administratively
like you know go down to the gas tent
check all the gas masks and stuff that
had all been done I'm kind of that 24
hours in between were you carrying the
radio
no I had a a radioman primary radio man
was right behind me and I had a had a
secondary radio man toward the end of
the patrol and you've taken what ten
seven eight guys ten guys something like
done guys I usually went heavy you know
so you got ten guys how many damn
batteries did you have to carry for an
eight day Patrol would you get
resupplied because were you using the
the 77 the prick 77 radio was one prior
to that blue or at prior I get pricked
25 for 25 yeah there you go
not necessarily the best thing but it
was pretty good yeah
line is Lunger line of sight yeah yeah
but but I mean you must have had to
carry a lot of batteries for that thing
we didn't I mean I guess the radio man
had extra batteries but we didn't
typically you know go through that much
battery man I was a radio man and it was
ridiculous the amount of batteries in
the early days cuz we got much smaller
radius later on and then come up water
which you guys just refill canteens on
rivers and whatnot we would if we could
find water but we went out with eight to
ten canteens because you didn't know
what are you gonna find water and if you
found it you don't know what it was
gonna be potable or not
but we were taking clay off and on I say
more often than not in the mountainous
type area mountainous being you know
thousand meters or higher and if we came
across running water that you know was
moving along I thought it was find safe
to drink until I went to this little one
day school put on where's chief corpsman
who talked about how the fill each larva
could be you know expelled into the
water and just bubbled down with the
water yes after that iodine tablets
every time we refill so never headache
problems how about food food we had
Korean air sea rats he's a Korean air it
Korean era Oh could really era 1954 it
would say on they're just playing sea
rats and cans
MREs were brand new
what's there and and but we occasion on
two patrols I think that we've managed
to steal some MRIs from somebody in the
army fine dining
yeah yeah but see they used water so
that was it was a it was a they were a
better meal but they would use water so
it was a six to one half a dozen to
another we and then would you guys
patrol during the day and then lay up at
night that's the frats affirmative yeah
we'd find the nastiest meanest video
taken at night and crawl in there and
harbor would be in our harbor site did
uh did they use dogs to try and find you
nope never saw a dog in Vietnam are in
the jungle anyway apparently a recon had
taken out dogs and handlers in the early
days and the dogs just couldn't handle
the heat and the terrain so they handler
we got up carrying the dog out
so that was a you guys know do you guys
bring claymores to set up around we did
what play marks claim works and
sometimes a little anti-personnel mines
which sounded like a great idea until
the next morning when the guy who'd put
them out
gotta go retrieve them yeah you got to
go receiving maybe has six mines out and
it kind of like what five Oh so we would
be moving out in the opposite direction
claim our was a good weapon it sounds
like you're you're you're op tempo was
like go on a patrol you're out there for
six seven days you come back you you
rest your refit you spend three four
days in camp something like that two or
three maybe two or three yeah yeah it's
a pretty pretty quick turnaround you
know you didn't have time to settle in
and get comfortable anywhere and then
it's back out were you guys just skinny
as could be we were yeah I went over
there waiting 150 pound front here 55
pounds which was my weight at the Naval
Academy came back I was 123 when I got
back but part of that was the previous
like nineteen days remember our shuttle
I got back in the States
I didn't eat too much yeah I was being
fed for one thing I know most the time
was red jello and I wasn't real
appealing I couldn't look at red jello
for about five years after that did you
do you guys have any night-vision at all
like a starlight scope yeah we had fixed
positions that we would go to for
sometimes for long as much as two weeks
and they were essentially high points
like a hill a hundred meter high hill
and they'd have a permanent radio we
have a permanent radio relay station on
there and and patrols would just rotate
there every couple of weeks to provide
security for that guy because he was up
there for like three plus months and on
those we would take we had starlight
yeah and we've watched the valleys and
stuff below us but never use them that
much you know you know going out in the
field that much you guys must have
really been I mean you guys must have
been really good and really efficient
out in the field after doing a field
after field op after field out for six
seven eight days every time did you feel
like you guys were kind of part of the
jungle at that point
never never felt really part of the
jungle but it certainly got more
comfortable in it
one thing that you always had to be very
careful about and in the work that recon
did was heat casualties you know you
took a serious heat candle that's an
emergency medevac which is again you
know announcing to the whole world of
this Marines out here and when I'm you
know down with the heat carefully as a
consequence the days we were back in the
area
first Platoon Delta Company pee-peed
every day people thought we were crazy I
took my heat casualties on Freedom Hill
Road you know running two and a half
miles down to an F miles back including
myself and I'm stopping to Barbara never
had a heat casualty in the five and a
half months I'm gonna patrol some was
very proud of
yeah if you gotta carry enough water for
that though really right no you just had
to ration yourself you know and each
individual LC said eight canteens you
bring in 1881 contains a lottery bet and
that's when I last year eight days
citrus citrus unless we got extended
which was not unheard of you know they
hit the Marine Corps helicopters would
be you know some operation would start
while you were on patrol they beat ask
for medevacs and you couldn't get out
the day were supposed to just you prayed
I guess would be the nice thing to say
that you got out the next day because by
then your food was exhausted your water
was either gone or shrill shark yeah we
used to have a lot we have a heat
casualties in training out here and
encountering out the Imperial Valley
where it's 120 degrees and it's tough
and like you said a guy can go from he's
fine to all sudden he's like a
legitimate length ology that again
matter that's right yeah
let's go to July 4th 1968 what was what
was going into that operation what was
the what was the overall operation that
you guys were looking to do we were
looking to find an old LZ a place called
Charlie Ridge you said you had uh
neighborhoods in the areas that were
hotter than others and hurmati we had
the same thing of course in Vietnam you
know some places were known as hot spots
he had almost guaranteed you know
somebody was gonna shoot a few rounds at
you coming in or going out if they
didn't find it during the or you didn't
find them during your patrol but we were
exposed to a flip-flop you know we'd go
in and another team would come out on
the top of this mountain and the team
had gotten lost they didn't know where
they were so they finally somehow you
know scraped there Sierra together and
and we went out we flip-flop with them
but we were way far away from the same
they were three or four thousand meters
away from this a mountaintop where we
were supposed to flip-flop with another
team
so I really pushed the patrol to find I
think this place must be really hard to
find if these guys couldn't find him
no no they just were lost but we found
that thing on the second day the old old
firebase on the top of this mountain you
know like three years of sea rats on the
side of the mountain because we had envy
a walking trail below us I'd stop and
have lunch eat old sees a ham and lima
beans I think supplied half the NVA in
Vietnam because the Marines just always
pitched those things nobody
we call them Hammond mothers nobody ate
them but so well he had a flip-flop so I
didn't want to get too far away from
this LZ because I run another LZ with
him you know three or four klicks so we
were gonna you know we harbor debt night
moved off into the jungle outside the LZ
our harbor that night had some big rocks
around us that we were very good
position and at night I would pre plot
fires you know artillery targets
north-south-east-west around our
position Casey had to call him in the
middle of the night you know figure out
what the what's our six you know numbers
here know these targets were already
plotted in so we woke up the next
morning and we were just gonna kind of
lay low all day long in that area wasn't
something you really wanted to do but
yes since we were scared of a flip-flop
and battalion really wanted us to do
that because it hadn't worked you know
when we had gone in we weren't we should
have gone in where we were going out but
they want something wanted to flip-flop
so I said the Lord is gonna lay low for
this day and we'll be out of here the
next morning well that morning I guess
some you know 12 men and behave recon
Patrol walked a close aboard or came by
close aboard I never heard him I just
they either saw a flash of emotion must
go we were eating breakfast or they
heard us which I don't think they did
because we were super quiet but all of a
sudden that just you know all this
automatic fire opened up and fortunately
was over our heads you know because
that's pretty typical happen in the
jungle
shoot hi but I had a big rock had it
behind me so I'm getting guys maneuvered
around starting to call the artillery
when a bullet apparently hits the rock
behind me comes back hits me in the head
from behind goes forward boom mom down
and I'm almost history next thing I know
my Kermit is doing a pat down on me
apparently the bullet had gone through
my floppy cover and didn't knock it off
and he wasn't till he saw blood starting
to run down the side of my face that I
realized the moon was up here but
because there was nothing visible so
he's doing a pat-down and I knew what
that meant
I knew I'd been shot and I knew he
didn't know where it was but I never did
figure out it was in my head or in the
head I could clue that sometimes that
morning because we were on a ground for
about another four hours before they
tried to get us out that I had been
bitten by a centipede it had some nasty
centipedes over there
whose the venom apparently attacked your
central nervous system so that was my
working theory that morning was that I
had been bit by a centipede how long
were you unconscious for you got hit I
was it unconscious just for a few
seconds because you know one minute I'm
kneeling I'm a lean green mean fighting
machine a next moment I'm a lying down
I'm a lean mean green stalk of broccoli
how much how much time had passed
between the the initial fire incoming
fire and you getting hit it was really
just a matter maybe of three to five
minutes okay you know I'm trying to get
guys positioned in recon we did not want
to fire back if somebody you know
started firing at you they didn't really
know where you were especially with this
fire going hi and the last thing you
wanted to do really was fire back was
this but now we know where they are and
then they you know so the deal was not
to fire back just bring in supporting
irons as quick as you could but
eventually of course the guys started to
fire back
it was just a little too hot and I just
thought of this I'm guessing you guys
wouldn't carry like a heavy machine gun
with you like an m60 or something no we
didn't too heavy and and then we have
two more guys tasked with ammunition
mm-hmm and you can't really you know I'm
getting all those things stuck quickly
and I need a jungle but occasionally we
did occasionally the you know the
pouring water that I would get from
battalion would say you know you're
taking an m60 on this patrol bigger
group had reports of X Y & Z in this
area and you might need it so great
obviously somebody had a volunteer to do
that and my littlest guy and sniffing it
was Mouse
he would always father carry the m60 a
great kid great good never really had to
use it in the jungle which was good but
Caitlyn would carry it so here you are
you're five minutes into this gunfight
you get hit you're unconscious for a
very short period of time and then you
come back to and how do you feel when
you come back again didn't know what
happened again my first thought was the
centipede thing but sounds were muffled
color it was gone things were moving in
black slowly and black and white around
me and sounds were very muffled by now
we they're killer we started to come in
we had a brand new second lieutenant
with us he was on his first snap-in
patrol he apparently assumed command
along with my experience corporal who
was my normally was the patrol leader
for this Patrol and together they they
managed the situation and we got
everybody out I was the only one who
wounded take that back
crew chief on the hill a copter that
picked us up was wounded he was on a 50
caliber and got hit in the hand but we
were the only two wounded I was the only
guy on my patrol water and the corpsman
standing the same class hospital man he
kept me alive for the next four hours
until I could get me then today how bad
were you bleeding
apparently bled out
there's a there's a cavity down the
center of your head call the superior
sagittal sinus it's like an upside down
triangle and it drains blood your brain
and that was nicked by the bullet
it was just close enough to midline to
nikla superior sagittal sinus
like murder my caramel just get bloody
battle battle dressing after battle
dressing on my head
everyone my whole day needless to say
we're you like passing back out and then
waiting back out I was I was I remember
I knew I could hear the helicopter
coming in and I knew we're about to
break out of the jungle to run to the Z
the helicopter was coming in that we had
been on the day before so I took all the
strength I could about to open my eyes
and look up and all I saw was tracers
confirms in kind of over us from all
plugs of the company Pam this is serious
you know who you're I got a I got a some
information that that your kids gathered
up and one of them one of them was a
note from Captain Frederick Rick Jay
Wilson the third and he woke this little
kind of description of what happened he
says I was the pilot of the ch-46 YT TAC
13 MMH 164 that rescued your team well
you couldn't know was that a lot of
people including your recon team
responsible for getting you to the
hospital I vividly remember the mission
because my crew chief was wounded that's
the guy you just talked to help he like
you also survived and prospered he and I
received Silver Stars for our actions
that day you tend to remember things
like that I flew 928 missions in Vietnam
and didn't have one was my hairiest I
first heard that your team was in
trouble and you were wounded when I was
landing at the neighing hospital with
another medevac because of your head
injuries I was able to get a corpsman at
the hospital before I headed out for the
rescue it turned out to be the corpsman
Terry Daley was from my hometown of
Wakefield Rhode Island I found this out
20 years later when Terry's wife showed
up at my sister's house with an old copy
and strife that covered the mission your
team evidently ran into an NVA base camp
that no one knew was there and was and
was greatly outnumbered because of your
wounds and the combat situation that
extraction was requested I was the
closest to the action the problems soon
became apparent that the team needed to
move about 200 yards to an old bomb
crater where I could land I called for
gunship support and some fast movers
what I got was four flights of phantoms
dropping bombs pretty close to the team
and for Huey gunships I was circling
overhead for about an hour before the
team got to the only feasible landing
zone on the ridge they did a good job
suppressing fire until I was landing
fortunately the bomb crater also
protected me somewhat and we were
getting we were we were able to get
everyone on board I was a little short
on fuel but that worked on my favor
because I was also about 2,000 pounds
over gross according to my co-pilot who
was wondering if we could lift off in
the meantime your team and my gunner
were engaged in a firefight your team
knocked out all the windows on my bird
but I didn't object because they were
covering my butt
we managed to take off and took a few
hits out on the way but thanks to the
Huey's escorting me I was able to dive
off the ridge and get out of range long
story short we weren't able to get
everyone to a hospital and the NVA got a
beating so he had to like just take off
and just fly over this Ridge right his
yeah apparently just kind of dove off
the ridge and you know eats food came
back up I heard that this that this
thing was so riddled with bullets this
helicopter was that the Marine Corps
helicopter facility was across the
highway from the impossible in the neck
they wouldn't fly it over there they
call for a tug to took to tow it over
there and we're gonna try to put that
thing back in the air that day man he
continues on it this was a nice I'm
taking like bits of this from a nice
letter that he wrote but he says I
understand
you count that day as an alive day which
is a very good thing to celebrate I was
probably one of the few Marines who
enjoyed their tour in Vietnam Thailand
primarily because I was saving lives and
rescue you Recon teams I also love the
flying since he would never let you fly
like that back in the States one of the
best things to come out of Vietnam was
the improvement of medical care you're
proof you are proof that as the survival
rates from Afghan as are the survival
rates from Iraq and Afghanistan I hope
you ever wonder wonderful 50th REE
birthday happy birthday marine and that
once again that's Captain Frederick Rick
Jay Wilson the third he was the command
pilot that day and a bird that told me
on the team out saved all our lives no
question about we did do you guys under
the threat of being overrun at some
point soon I tell the truth Jocko I have
no idea of really my memory of that day
was pretty sketchy
I'd I talked to him on the phone last
year and he said they had a circle
overhead for an hour because they just
couldn't set it down there was no
possible way and they estimated probably
200 NBA on the ground and that's part of
the reason why they weren't able to fly
it back to it squadron because small
arms fire through rotor blades you know
as an infantry officer I always felt
very comfortable on the ground and very
exposed on a helicopter I just figure
those four things were flying magnets
that made a lot of noise and but of
course the the aviators felt just the
other way they were felt safe in their
bird and we never wanted to be on the
ground but never I had that I feel the
exact same thing as you I don't I just
never liked any sort of machine I didn't
I didn't like any of them I wanted to
just be on my feet exact you know and
yeah that feeling that you have an ala
copter where you're up flying and all
you see is all you all I see when I'm
flying a helicopter is threats and you
know and you can't even come close to
cover law at least on the ground I can I
can cover some of the threats when
you're in an aircraft it's like
I'm waiting to get shot - that's what it
feels like to me when you when you
remember coming to or when you remember
what they do with you once you got in
the hospital you remember much of that
no I
I remember the the helicopter landing
because that my head bounced on the
middle
damn couldn't but someone anything my
head I remember them picking me up and
put me on our stretcher because they
grabbed my belt and picked them pick up
my middle and it felt like I felt like a
girl just going right through me I
faintly remember the sound of hearing
this guy that sound like it was on the
other side of a football field saying
negative vitals negative vitals negative
vales and then the next thing I felt
this rush on my chest like that that's
okay because you know they're getting
the heart back up checking you know oh
so they were like doing CPR yeah yeah
well I was parently resuscitated three
times just after the helicopter landed
at the NSA denying the hospital but my
corpsman had been straddling me the
whole time in Gila copy room was pushing
on a heart to keep keep blood flowing
and it was say not my best day but you
know oh yeah what I'm here talking about
it so yeah that he'll take you that
might have a huge difference believe me
because there's no reason I should be
when I left Bethesda after a year my
attending physician was the chief of
Neurosurgery he called me in his office
and said hey I can't okay I wish it
medicine could take credit for this but
nah he said we can't he says I don't
know what it's whatever you want to call
it you know karma luck God whatever you
want to call it I wish it was medicine
but it's blessing I figured he was a
prettty leading expert on head injuries
how long so you you get you get to the
hospital and you're there at some point
they must have got you stabilized
they must have yeah as I understood that
the the chief neurosurgeon from the
hospital ship just happened to be there
that day like give it an in-service and
I'm like that and
they were on me like flies on steak I
just remember waking up being extremely
cold and hearing a baby cry cry and cry
and cry and I said this can't be right
I'm a man maybe I'm not here you know
but sure enough it turned out there was
a farmer told me later in a couple days
later that there was a baby that had
been burned you know due to a u.s. force
action who was you know this was like a
ward that was a tensive care ward
apparently and there was a baby and a
couple of mama signs and the baby did
cry almost all the time that's what I
remember my troops came just say goodbye
22 of them they let him in groups of 2
all I could do was cry I just I didn't
have words for other than say he's like
keep your head down and stuff like that
but I knew by then that I had a head
injury and I knew it just slowly gone I
mean no one told me you know that this
left side was paralyzed along with my
right leg no one told me that it just
came to me over time when I would try to
do something the only way I could get
attention so I had this perfect left
paralysis down side my faith would talk
like that I've raised my hand they tied
it down for the bed rails because that's
all the IVs were in the right arm well I
was I would helpless I I wasn't I've
never been so miserable as that moment
when I tied that arm down and it's just
the trauma to your brain that it caused
you to be paralyzed in your left arm and
and was your left side here my left side
of my body in the right leg it was a the
bullet had blown away a 3 by 7
centimeter defect in my skull and it had
penetrated the meninges nicked the
parietal lobe and the frontal lobes and
tore the superior sagittal sinus oh
that's a woman that's incompatible with
life as we know it but Here I am telling
you about it so
you know one of your one of your guys
once again your your kids at an awesome
job getting scattering some information
one of your guys Robert Wood daily Baird
the third no and you're a third - I'm
second okay I I fought it for some
reason he says he said he thought that
you were third but yeah so he's the
third he was a Lance Corporal in first
Platoon Delta Company first recon
battalion and he talks about and he
starts off kind of tell him what it was
like for him to beat you and how
impressed he was with you as a leader
and actually felt what you talked about
earlier was like you know that he could
tell that you you cared about the troops
and then it gets to this point where
he's coming they're coming out this
journey to say goodbye to you and so
here's what Robert Wood daily bear the
third says he says then that afternoon
the team made a solemn journey to the
Naval Hospital to see the lieutenant
everyone watched the scenery without
really seeing it as we rode along in a
six by truck we were too worried about
him we arrived and went to neuro ward
Bravo - we can only see him two at a
time and since I was new I was last I
waited when my teammates came out they
looked pale then it was my turn
I was nervous I entered the world ward
it was lengthy with empty racks here at
the near end each rack was covered with
a crisp white sheet ready for its next
visitor on a long shelf on the right
there were plastic models of planes
ships and cars that the patients had
made I walked onward one of the
healthier men was putting together a
model plane on the left was an ancient
papasan
with white hair his beard a dirty gray
contrasted with his hospital tunic a
nurse with an angelic voice attracted my
attention I noticed her face firm with
conviction and wondered how I how she
could work in such a tragic place she
was feeding a baby
seeing that struck me deeply the baby
was burned over 70% of its body
I pressed onward but paused wondering
what I should say
patience filled the beds at this end of
the ward unhealed wounds burns scars and
vacant stares stabbed out at me half of
a face there no eyes and no arm legs
here bodies covered with gauze seemingly
mummified the morbid display made me
realize how truly bad war is but the
worst was yet to come I passed
Harry Mun Dorf and Rudy Seville they
were coming out somehow they didn't look
the same as when I'd seen them a short
time ago there he was in the last raft
on the left he lay on his right side and
glanced up with glazed eyes when I
approached a turban of bandaged bandages
covered his head his pale face showed no
emotion except sadness and his eyes were
red from crying all the time we talked
he stared at the airborne parachute
wings on my chest as if they were
something he wanted very badly he told
me when I had first joined the platoon
that he hadn't gone to jump school yet
and that he was looking forward to it
he started by saying hello Baird how you
doing I said good afternoon sir I'm fine
his voice was weak like a child who was
afraid at times I could barely hear him
he added again to the conversation by
thanking all of us and I replied that it
had been the least we could do then I
asked him if he'd be back at recon in
three months or so a tear came to his
eye and he said he would never be coming
back you see he said my legs are
paralyzed I choked up and my skin
crawled and I was unable to speak a
silenced cold and heavy a silenced cold
and heavy prevailed finally he broke the
silence saying Baird
you're a big man and there's something I
want you to do keep your head down there
keep your head down when you're out of
the bush this statement hit me and
grabbed in my heart and I screamed
inside myself deep deep down somewhere
that I never knew existed I promised him
that I would would and bid him my
fondest farewell turned and walked away
I wanted to run from him from them
the whole world I wanted to run past
those helpless men in those metal beds
out to the street and far far away but I
kept my control and walked at a brisk
pace the echoes of that scream resounded
inside me again and again threatening to
tear me apart
suddenly the anguish melted away as I
stepped out into the brutal tropic Sun
but the feeling that I had still ran
like hot lava through my veins the ride
back home was the same no one looked at
the scenery or at each other nor talked
with anyone
each was involved with their own
memories of second lieutenant Charles
Robert Eisenbach the second he was a man
with such a brilliant mind and
exuberance to be alive now he lay in a
hospital suffering a far worse fate to
him than death his once healthy body was
now frail and flimsy like a person who
had always been an invalid left only was
his mind and he had too much time to
think and reflect upon what had happened
and what was going to happen it was a
great strain and shock to see him with
hope he will work his way back because
he does have guts and what's interesting
about that that's a that's a heavy you
know rendering of what happened but
that's actually from his personal
journal that he kept while he was in
Vietnam those are the thoughts of
whatever probably a 20 year old kid
seeing this unfold yeah
well needless to say alas Carol Baird I
think he had a year of college it was
kind of a platoon spokesman he became a
writer and a poet so he you know he
obviously had a great command of the
English language and maybe saw some
things or invented some things that
weren't necessarily there but that was
his reality that's fine with me I can't
can't argue with it nothing he said in
there I don't think was untrue I was
what we call a hurt and Gator fact I
remember they they told me that I was
going to an Army Hospital in in Japan
well only thing I knew was that Marines
when they got wounded
we anomaly went to a Naval Hospital in
Yokohama so I just pistol little hissy
fit and said why are you sending me to
an Army Hospital not knowing that this
Army Hospital in Camp Drake outside of
Ketchikan Air Force Base in Japan was
where all head injuries what that was
their specialty was headed head injuries
so they finally got a doc in there to
calm me down and and tell me how this
was the place I needed to be and one
Hospital was just as good as another
which of course you don't believe when
when it's not you your services hospital
but hey you know I was 23 old kiddo and
you know I had been a naval hospitals
before I had had always gotten great
care and that's what I was expecting and
it turned out this general Support
Hospital that I ended up that was
first-rate I was there for like ten days
before I was a stable enough to to make
the plane trip back home and interesting
place surface attendees you're there
they do any why are they doing surgeries
aren't you or are they just trying to
let you heal up they're just kind of
letting me heal up in there they've
started physical therapy on my had
tremendous spasms in both my legs and my
in my left arm so they had physical
therapy make some braces that they put
on my feet and it made a hand brace
where I was my thumb sticking out like
this and one of my arm would spaz this
thing come to beat me in the high I have
to hold this arm down
I was miserable there was just a young
kid to like to my right who'd lost and I
was an Air Force airman and had lost her
anion denying and that was just that was
this problem that was a major problem
and he had been tasked to be my feeder
and my smoker you know it was a smoker
that it and I would just crave a camel
and he'd have to be around to handle it
because I couldn't deal with it but
terrific kid and his and they really
they took excellent care of me in this
hospital just like it did everybody else
so the the spasms in your arms and legs
which we were all immediately all of us
just laughed when you told that story
that is pretty disturbing but
that had to be a little bit of a good
sign because some kind of spasm means
that there's some nerve signal get in
there well exactly and what it was was a
screwed-up signal in always there wasn't
you know telling the thing to do
anything useful it was just you know
telling these muscles to fire you know
again from the from the damage to area
in my brain as I understand it and
looking back on it but that was your
where's your mindset that you're going
now from hey I mean when you said you
were paralyzed when you initially got
hit and now you know you can't move your
leg you can't move your every one of
your legs or your left arm right right
but and what did you in your mind did
you think okay I might be this might be
it you know I might be paralyzed like
this forever well of course you don't
know what the future holds I mean none
of us do but the better you become the
more aware you become of your
limitations and yeah you start to think
you know how long is this gonna last is
this forever what am I gonna do for the
rest of my life you know you know you're
not gonna be a marine guys you know have
a job description Murray's fruit you
know in wheelchairs like that but the
one saving grace I always thought was
while I'm single at least there's not
you know a wife involved and a child on
the way like most of my contemporaries
had but conversely the guys who were you
know as I found out later on it
professor the guys who were married felt
it was much better to be married because
you had this you know direct support
system but you were coming back into and
you know you knew this woman was gonna
be there they all they weren't of course
always you know things don't last a lot
of times when you get big changes like
that in your life unfortunately but the
guys were married that'll be much better
to be married and those of us who were
single that was much better to be single
but sure you say you know that's the
first question out of here your mind is
when you get to your final destination
which for me with Bethesda Naval
Hospital was dot how long am I gonna be
here well they don't have any idea they
don't know how
Recovery's gonna unwind so finally my
doctor said to me hey you could be here
for two years and I can't guarantee that
you'll walk out even then I thought to
myself oh damn he doesn't know who he's
dealing with my plane I got shot on a
fourth of July my plan was to be back in
Vietnam by Christmas with my guys you
know that didn't work out but that was
my plan uh-huh you know and I work hard
to make it happen it didn't happen you
know a year later I walked out of there
under my own power with a leg brace and
a cane and got out an ambulance and was
driven down the road 95 go to the VA
hospital in Richmond Virginia where I've
stayed to another four months but you
don't know what's gonna happen at here's
it's a it's it's a slowly evolving you
know kind of mental process you go
through yeah you hit a point I I did and
I know how the guys did too cuz we
talked about this well you'd say why me
you know why me God well I just happen
to me and I don't know if other guys got
there got an answer to that question but
I did I over time this answer evolved
you know and the answer was why not you
Eisenbach
who are you you're no better than
anybody else I put down that little blue
planet but you're no worse either so
you're just gonna have to go with the
punches and that's the answer you know
why not you you're no better and no
worse than anybody else I mean that's a
little hard for I think for some people
to stomach but that was the answer I got
and you know it's it served its purpose
okay
why not me this is it this is the way it
is I guess and what I yeah I just have
to take it a day at a time and do my
best to get better and see where I end
up and and when I get to that point you
know I'll make decisions about what I'm
gonna do for the future which I you know
I did and now I had a lot of locational
counseling from the VA when I get
flushed you know out out of the service
and out of the VA system I got a lot of
look like I several occasional camps I
got interest tests that I take you know
because the question now is okay what am
I gonna do for the rest of my life well
not surprisingly I scored highest on
military officer
she I just was one of those a couple of
months ago second highest was FBI agent
oh that sounds good but again they don't
have job description for guys who limp
you know and finally it is court third
on teacher I said yeah that's
interesting and that evolved and the
thing about becoming a therapist and
specifically a speech therapist I had a
speech defect that I just kind of
overcame myself at Bethesda by slowing
down and trying to think about what I
was gonna say before I said it
and I got the nickname Spock because my
speech became very delivered but when I
was just spontaneous apparently and I
never heard this but my roommate would
say Eisenbach
I said what he said always with that
language I said what life you know we
maybe had some visitors couple of gals
from people I know who are overseas him
getting up he said it was chant it was
filthy that's it
really I never heard it and I said yeah
so I started to slow down myself and
fight it think about what I would say
but speech therapists kind of stuck in
my mind after this vocational counseling
that I got that's eventually what I
became was a speech-language pathologist
so he's saying you're said speech was
filthy you mean you were like swearing
oh yeah oh yeah just using every filthy
word lightly like uh what's that
Tourette syndrome is that what it's all
about so let's enjoy it I mean I had no
idea that I was doing that I didn't hear
cuz what you just did it naturally like
that's how you talked kind of thing or
like why didn't you remember it I know
it wasn't how I normally would speak it
was just it would just come out and
totally the in a totally inappropriate
situation you're not amongst the guys
but you know amongst visitors you know
and like I said I didn't know what's
going on but you uh you kind of glanced
over the fact that that you know you've
got the feedback hey you can't you can't
stay in the Marine Corps anymore and you
it sounds like you you figured that out
yourself but at some point that's that's
got to turn into a harsh reality or
that's what you wanted to do you're in
Vietnam your platoon commander you got
the best guys in the world and all of a
sudden in one day it's gone it's right
it's gone and you don't know what's
gonna replace it but yeah eventually you
get before a physical evaluation board
and what I had hoped for because most of
most of my roommates and most of the
guys there I knew that had Marines they
had orthopaedic industries you know
they've got stitched up with a machine
gun in their legs or whatever they got
put on the temporary disabled retired
list that allowed you five years to
regain your ability and and if you could
you you you would get a chance to go
back into the Marine Corps on the other
hand if you got better the VA could drop
your disability rating down so it was
kind of a double-edged sword most guys
just wanted to get out but for guys like
me that they call lifers because I
wanted I wanted a career right and I
argued that I could fly any desk well
that that was fine but that wasn't gonna
that wasn't that wasn't gonna fly I was
gonna be retired but as long as I was on
the T DRL the temporary disabled retires
this I thought well I got a chance but I
got a I met the VA hospital not but I've
been through my physical evaluation
board they've asked me questions and
I've got a transcript of it my doctor
submitted statements and stuff like that
and they said well we'll look at you on
the T DRL and I said great cuz I'd have
five years to work myself back in the
Corps came through my loaders for
retirement or came through one day and
when I was in the bleeding Hospital
permanent disabled retired US no chance
of ever getting back boy yes beyond just
talking about I was on the phone to the
Secretary Navy's office which I got
through to and I had some nice older
woman right there who obviously had her
this story before you know I was
promised that T DRL but I've here I've
been permanently retired she said well
lieutenant you've got to understand that
you know we've done this a few times
before and we kind of know the the
history of these kinds of injuries and
your board did recommend the permanent
retired disabled this not that temporary
so you know we have to go with what they
say and of course they were right
but again you know I was you know I'm
right now I'm old man at 24 right and
I'm being retired excuse me I didn't
that's not the plan but that's how it
all worked how long did it take you to
realize how long did it take you to
accept that so you you kind of got
through the the why me why not bread
bread how did you how long did it take
you to get through this fact that okay
now the Marine Corps your your sacred
Marine Corps has has made this decision
you know I'm still thinking about some
50 odd years that's right yeah I'm still
now I got a new why me questionnaire but
no I I I adjusted I went down to
graduate school got a master's degree in
a the speech Department the University
of Florida and they weren't quite sure
what had walked through the door when
apparently when I arrived I wanted to
know where the coffee mess was and
they're all look at me like the what
well you know the place where you get
you just drop in the morning get a cup
of coffee and pay a dime or whatever
well we don't know what they like that
we're gonna get one do now we do now
that's right and most of my classes were
on the third floor of this building
which had an elevator from went up to
the third floor but it didn't work
hadn't worked in years and so I went to
my advisor I said look this three
flights of stairs has killed me
throughout three times a day you know we
got to get that elevator work as well
can't do it like no way hasn't worked
since I've been here the prophecy I said
well we'll see about that he said well
what are you gonna do I said well I'm
gonna go talk to the president the
president what President President Lee
University except you can't do that
really
watch me so I did he wasn't there but
his it's like chief of staff was who
happened to be a guy who had kind of a
an arm injury from World War two and he
said well it can't be repaired can it
that's what they're telling me sir is it
I'll take care well next day it was
working just fine and work for the next
three years my Master's broke down day
how uh we kind of we kind of jumped over
this part how long were you in Bethesda
for total I was in Bethesda for a little
over 12 months and and throughout that
time you know when you showed up when
you got wounded you could move your
right your legs or arm
what was the progression like getting
you back to - you know the best I
goodnight yeah well it was a physical
therapy occupational therapy you know
once today which I decided once a day
was good twice might be better so I
argued for that and pretty soon I got
that by November my right leg had
started to get remarkably better my left
leg still wasn't real useful but that
you put a brace on it and and I could
bite November I was walking not granted
I had a crush on one side on the right
side a loft ran correct you know the
metal things and called polio crutches
back then but I don't know what their I
called off grand crutches because that's
a guy who invented and acquirement on my
left side but I was walking you know and
of course they went back to I found
dropped the corpsman and and went to two
loft grant crutches dropped the right
the left one after a while back to the
right one then dropped that to a cane
and the leg brace on my left and I did
fine for about 42 years that way about
eight years ago my right leg decided to
take an early retirement on me and so I
had to start wearing a brace on that leg
and and I was falling too much so they
put me into an electric wheelchair which
is what I scoot around a house and
around town and
that scooter over there is what it flies
my my I will cheer it out and fly it's
247 pounds and it doesn't fly but that
flies that breaks down into four or five
parts of my wife can do it usually by
Iran of course this weekend we've had
the kids to help her you just throw it
that back up low I know some of the
girls though speaking you've fallen down
some of the notes had you uh wearing a
football helmet while you were down
there
it sounds like that made of quite an
impact on some of the places that you'd
visit with your football helmet on well
you know I was falling when I started
that you know walk independently at the
hospital and I had a left foot drop
which means the brace was supposed to
bring it up so it clears all the little
obstacles and there you don't have to
pay attention to when you got to good
feet but I would fall into elevators
because they wouldn't re-exam
and I'd fall into everybody in there so
eventually I started they get they say
you need a football helmet yeah because
you got the right right I've got I've
got a defect up there you could put your
hand in my defect and take it take my
pulse just like this where I squeeze
hard the thing would pop up but wouldn't
you get a titanium plate in there oh
that was after about a year at the end
of them a year they waited a year before
they put a plate in your skull because
it was considered at a minute the
contaminated ruled I'm not sure what
that meant to the medical people but it
meant to me it meant you waited a year
and put the plate in but so this
football helmet my dad got it from the
University of Delaware where he worked
and it was blue with you if I'm Michigan
saying with you know yellow stripes so
in occupational therapy I got a can of
olive graft painted with my makeup you
did everything with my lab I spray
painted this thing I loved rap my
roommate at the time he had been there
long and I had and apparently I was the
the perfect roommate for him because I
had lost my sense of smell and taste and
apparently he'd been in a body spica
cast from here you know dad it was nice
for like six months and he stunk to high
heaven so I didn't smell up so I was
probably the perfect his sister got this
button book where you had a blank button
and a bunch of things you could put on
the button and but it also had some you
know bullet holes with the shattered
glass strike Thanks so I pull post on
the front of the front of the of the
football Hamlet and and I had a a little
badge
well maybe three inches around said my
head is a depressed area and I'd wear
that on my mom my bathrobe around the
hospital my guy
nobody would drop and look at me I'd
read that look at me at home and they
just they can't move up out of the way
they didn't want to mess with this guy
he might have been crazy dark dark
humorous popular we are family well dark
humor you know it Bethesda at that time
there was probably all always about a
dozen of us young lieutenants you know
between the 8th floor and the 14th floor
of the Roosevelts erection the tower
anyway and we had we didn't know it at
the time but we had a great group
dynamic going on there was always
someone who was worse off than you so
when you started to feel sorry for
yourself I started to get down your
buddies would come in as hey what about
you yeah what about ice Mike over there
what about but Tucci over here so-and-so
Smitty hmm and and sure enough there was
always somebody better off that he was
putting up the good fight so you know
you never got too down on yourself those
are those are important lessons that you
know for life right you bet you bet I
mean we can complain I'll be there for
I'll be the person complaining about oh
I oh I I jammed my finger and I want
that about it cuz I can't do something
that's like no what you need to do is be
quiet and as I always say do what you
can you know your can so you get down
somehow I'll go back to college you got
the elevator work it
you got a and how long does it take you
how long it can take to get your your
doctor would you get your doctorate in I
got my doctor and speech-language
pathology you know with a minor in
psychology but at first I had to get the
master's and I I'm not sure how the
University of Florida looked at my
transcript from the Naval Academy and
how they factored in you know weapons
the navigation and and course like that
I thought I took but I had to do a whole
lot of a undergraduate courses before I
could you know move into the graduate
level course so it took me I think about
three years to get the master's degree
going to school full-time and the VA was
you know picking up the tab for that VA
it's been very good to me I'm very good
and I know there's a lot of complaints
out there about the VA and I'm sure some
of them are warranted to some degree or
another but you've got to understand
with the VA you know it doesn't happen
yesterday doesn't happen five minutes
from now
it happens it'll happen down the road
but as long as you you know check every
box and go from a B C D and try to jump
from A to F you know it'll all work for
you mm-hmm great outfit at what point
did you meet meet Jerry I met sherry
after I had my master's degree and I
worked for a year down in Orlando at an
Easter Seals community and was a great
experience my one of my little profs at
the University of Florida invited me to
come back up to the Medical Center there
and become one of the staff speech
pathologists at the Medical Center and I
said great which so I did that Sheri was
a staff occupational therapist had an
office that kind of across the hall from
me we met we met and being dull normal
about these things like most men
apparently I I didn't catch on fast
enough so we had a mutual friend it
wasn't the other master speech
pathologist there and she had us over
for dinner one night great and then I
still I still didn't get it so we were
at a convention one time one summer and
we were having lunch together and myself
and the other speech pathologist who was
also a friend of Sherry's and she said
Ike what do you why do you think I
invited you and sherry over for dinner
you like this
she said listen if you don't when we get
back from this convention if you don't
ask her out in two weeks
she's gonna ask you uh oh so you know I
asked her out and we went out we did it
for a while and eventually you know
everything fell into place with and we
got engaged meanwhile I had kind of
given up on marriage I had dated a fair
amount and you know I was just running
into wall after wall so but I decided
you know I want to be a dad I love kids
I'd always loved kids so I went to the
Children's Aid Society of Florida and I
wanted to adopt a kid oh well back then
it and this was now the late 60s early
70s they looked at either like you had a
hole in your head of course which I did
so that was okay but I'm mad but they
said look they gave me all the stuff to
read and all his exercises to go through
and said yeah you come back in a couple
of months and if you still want to
pursue this thing we'll talk about it
well so I did and this process took
about nine months but eventually I was
approved I mean they my everybody my
family had to submit the letters and all
my friends and they just they sliced and
diced me one side up one side and down
the other cuz they weren't gonna let one
of their kiddos get in a home some kind
of freaky guy yeah and which you totally
understand but getting engaged all that
went away you know if you're gonna get
married that's what they want they
wanted obviously a two-person situation
for their kids and a staple so if you
got engaged or something like that
during that this process it was over but
I had been accepted and sure enough as
soon as we got engaged I call my
caseworker and told her just a great way
to go and book things adoptions off
though okay okay that's fine we'll do it
the old-fashioned way which we did I did
and at this time you still
suing your doctor and at this time I am
pursuing my doctorate at this time
that's right yeah and that was about
seven years going to school halftime and
working halftime you know I'd get a
fellowship at the VA and you know
halftime research fellowship er or
clinical fellowship and stuff like that
and go to school halftime my VA money
had run out by then so I was funding
this which was fine with me and then at
some point you get you finished with the
marriage you get married and you start
having kids this is true
Matt Matt he's a third kid oh there we
go
my time to shine yeah this is your
moment
what uh what was it like for you yet
growing up with the dad you know I I
don't think it was a typical childhood
compared to my friends he would charge
in her and it probably felt like 4:00 in
the morning but it was probably more
like seven o'clock
wake us out we'd all be out in the
hallway in line like formed up ready to
go prior to school and he would you know
do what he called belly Busters that was
basic morning PT with the family you
know obviously like it was very limited
but we did like push-ups sit-ups jumping
jacks want to see how fast it's about to
the one thing I was they get up
yeah and so it was just like I don't
think anybody else's kids did that at
the time yes right
there you go uh-huh you would wake us up
by like playing revelry you know I knew
what revelry was before I joined the
military it was it was they couldn't
chew gum it was somewhat control cast
there was a lot of discipline there that
maybe other kids didn't have we got a we
got put on restriction which I didn't
know what that was until I went to naps
and I supposed to be grounded as opposed
to being grounded on restriction and
that's just what it was called and we
had to like explain what it was to our
friends and respect you what is that
so we have to explain that's being
grounded yeah he was kind of like this
this a hero to like a lot of our friends
though because he was like he was really
good with our friends and he was just
like kind of like a wild man he was
notorious throughout the school system
of not being a guy to mess with if you
were like a school administrator
I think the kids I'm not in the notes
but I'll tell this story I think it was
sixth grade and I had a friend who would
get in trouble in class regularly and
you know what you know I'm the youngest
kid so a lot of teachers knew who I was
and my sisters were probably better at
school at that time than I was and so
you know the teacher pulls me aside one
day and she's okay you need to stop
being friends with Chino
just a bad influence on you and so I go
home tell my dad that yes well we'll see
next day like it's you know the school
that has like the loudspeaker that like
clicks on from when the office calls and
I think you know one of the one of the
office staff is like uh yeah mister
Schneiderman I think mister Eisenbach is
here she was like oh great I'll send
Matt down to the office and you could
kind of hear it in the voice of the
office staff and they're like no no he's
he's here to see you and the whole class
is just like what is happening so yeah
it was is clearly different you know
it's you know the growing up with like
somebody that is like the essence of the
rancor like discipline kind of like
iron-fisted it's what people think
but fair sure yeah that's what we're
contes that's most of the time like you
there are things that you know you just
have to do because that's way I want
them done or that's why I'm in our house
right which is like that's what he wants
so you know you kind of had to grow up
learning just to like you know roll with
that sort of stuff which is you know a
lot of what you see in the military is
like we do things this way just cuz it's
the way we do it um or it's because the
way out I want it but you know not
everything is like that in the military
you know you get you know input which oh
like eight years old I have a lot of
input in things but so at what point did
you decide you were to go to the Naval
Academy uh like him we would schedule
trips around the Annapolis area to go
visit friends and we'd wind up you know
at the academy or you know we
psychological warfare right we'd go we
go to San Diego for spring break and go
check check out the Naval Station things
like that and so you know I've kind of
known for a while I hope you know I'm
gonna be a pilot that's kind of what I
want to do and I think the best way to
go about that is probably good with an
able cat
and so I had probably early high school
kind of had that idea in mind like him I
probably wasn't the best student ever I
got better over time but at that time I
don't really like put a lot of effort
into school and homework so I had to get
out what was called Naval Academy prep
school which is just you know basically
an academic year to get you ready for
the Naval Academy I found out about
restriction there well I'll tell you if
I can my one of my favorite stories
about Matt was when he was getting ready
to apply for the Naval Academy you know
I thought he had taken the PSAT or
whatever that is a preset and I thought
well we kind of bump this up a little
bit so you know I'll challenge him so I
made a bet with our I bet I can score
higher on the SAT that you can he looks
me like of course I got three heads and
14 ears
oh good so I I meanwhile has
strategically bought some of these uh
prep books that I was leaving around the
house what we played a win over here
that's right
yes what would he would buy into those
you know he didn't but we scheduled the
SAT and we took it man
the results come back and you know you
got to be careful what you wish for
I had scored a minute I had like a 650
or 750 out of 800 on the English side
he's looks he's dead no one ever gets
750 English so that all just came back
to haunt me you know I beat upon that
but Nate here you know yeah a lot of
things going for him he was an Eagle
Scout
he'd lettered in a couple of sports at
high school and he did he had a good
interview with a blue and gold officer
fella who kind of recruits for the Naval
Academy and you know around the area and
they got him all over the country
probably helps that he knows all those
people too
well I don't think so but and I didn't
know anybody on the on the admissions
board it wouldn't helped if I did you
got in there yourself but you ended up
being a submariner though mm-hmm
you know the Naval Academy like any
selection program is gonna be tough and
there's only a limited number of spots
and there's you know physical
requirements after me you know I have
20/20 vision anymore so probably being a
pilot was not in in the in the works for
me so I just went you know I think I got
selected as a Surface Warfare Officer
and then you know I didn't necessarily
want to do that I wanted to do something
different or more challenging and so I
wouldn't ask to be a submarine officer
and you have to you have to ask to get
an interview with the naval reactors
personnel and so you know I wouldn't saw
the captain on the yard who was the head
submarine officer there and you know he
looked at all my stuff and said you
picked the wrong major I was an econ
major at the time and again probably to
have the best grades ever but I was good
enough in math and science that he let
me through onto the Naval reactors
interview so I went from there you got
to go still kind of like old school
where you used to have to go interview
with Admiral rickover and he'd play mind
games with you they still they keep that
tradition alive
you still go interview with the
four-star that's head of naval reactors
but fewer mind games more just you know
technical interview and then go and how
many years did you end up your I did 6 I
got out in 2012 July of that year so
just a little over six years and so like
what are you doing now I am what I call
fully retired and enjoying it immensely
after after my speech pathology career
kind of it just kind of petered out here
in the Pacific Northwest it's a whole a
different atmosphere and ballgame for
halide health professionals than it is
on the East Coast which was okay but so
I
in about 1995 I went into selling life
insurance and mutual funds which which I
enjoyed but wasn't wildly successful at
but was successful enough to you know
pay the bills and keep some income
coming in but finally I I ditched that
and decided to live a life of leisure
she always say but you know every day is
a little bit different you know getting
up in the morning it's not typical you
got to get braces on and and make sure
you don't fall out of bed you know one
of my theories is gravity always wins
and it always does you know so and
everything's just a little bit more
difficult but it's okay it sure beats
being a Taunton kind of looking up with
the sod which is where I theoretically
should be well we are certainly glad
that you didn't end up there egg wise
and that you ended up here it's a it's a
probably a good place to wrap it up just
awesome to sit and talk with you well
likewise chuckle did you have any
closing thoughts Matt anything that I
missed I don't have any closing thoughts
well just one thought here's it's as you
will almost always miss in the service
and frankly in any kind of industry or
stuff like that and that's the the part
that your spouse place for you my wife
has been terrific over the last 41 years
she's a the level of my life and be the
mother of my children and you know I I
just I don't think I could get through a
week without her she she helps me she
points out where I'm you know turning
left when I maybe we should stay the
straight and narrow you know she's a
good cook she's pretty good at
management
[Music]
[Laughter]
well and I love her dearly
well that's that's awesome and yeah like
we can often overlook the the the
families you know whether it's right the
husband the wife the kids they all make
a huge sacrifice but for those that are
still in the military you know they
always make the sacrifice we were to
support you know their spouse so
absolutely to the families out there
that are out there supporting the
spouses thank you to you all and sir you
know it's it's just an honor to sit here
and talk with you and and thank you
thank you for coming on the show more
importantly though obviously thank you
for your for your service and your
sacrifice you as well go ahead also you
yes yeah well we're waiting on that echo
everybody serves in their own way we we
you know the sacrifices that you made
the efforts that you made you know it's
what allows us to be here today as a
free people doing what we're doing so
thank you for for put your your own
safety and your own life on the line for
this country and we deeply appreciate it
well like you were here serve us again
and for all those out there who have
served and are serving you know get
something awesome thanks like free Tibet
and with that Charles Robert Ike
Eisenbach has left the building
and honor to have him on to talk to hear
his perspective kind of a crazy life
starting with growing up in the
Philippines
yeah well the father his dad sound like
a character yeah a character he's like
yeah the he's like from the Philippines
right but not technically Filipino so
you know yeah you're from the
Philippines like not computing it's good
interesting stuff and this is awesome
for us to sit here and of course get to
get to talk with another hero another
individual that just steps up and
overcomes reminding me reminding us
right that we need to do more that we
can do more
is there anything echo Charles that you
recommend that we should all do yeah
what is it
jujitsu okay course okay I think of the
many reasons to do jujitsu I think we've
concluded number one is that it's fun
that should be however I don't know if
it's the biggest reason I'm not sure
it's the reason that will keep you with
it oh yeah there's so many strong
reasons though we'll just say fun /
beneficial here's the weird thing like
on social media somebody asked me all
these different questions mmm all these
different questions about what would you
do if what would you do if you have
trouble controlling your temper do
jujitsu what do you do if you have
trouble detaching or what's your good
way to learn to detach do Jiu Jitsu
what's a good workout to start getting
in shape to Jiu Jitsu what's a good way
to let off steam and not get stressed
out Jiu Jitsu you see what I'm saying
yes it's Just Answer ANSWER Answer is
your answer so yeah pretty much across
the board what we are saying do Jiu
Jitsu yes when you do Jiu Jitsu you got
to have a key for sure you're gonna need
a key so when you do key this is the key
you're gonna get or Jinky it's not just
one origin geek get as many as you want
but you have different selections what
I'm saying I'm saying so one of the
reasons to get an origin key not that
it's fun it is fun to get in or Jinky
for sure it is fun to get it origins but
oddly enough they're factually the best
well more person feels when they shop
yes yeah ever thought what do they call
it like some therapy like shop therapy
is that what it's called shop therapy
yeah it's called so no well yeah I don't
know if
but it's that situation where it's like
therapeutic to go shopping some people
just go window-shopping i think what i
have you ever heard me rage against
consumerism cuz i'll do it right now
well you know by everything right yeah I
think what happens is there's a certain
level of gratification that you get from
building something making something
right yes whether it's a brick wall
whether it's a rien drywall in the
kitchen like it there's a there's a
satisfaction that you get from it from
creating something yeah well I hate to
say it but sometimes for some people
shopping starts to kind of replace that
and and you know they want to create
something cool they can just click on
Amazon and it's common and they kind of
get a little bit a little dose of it
feels good yes so there is that when you
buy an Origin key I will say you feel a
little bit what's better though is when
you buy an Origin key what you kind of
feel you look when you buy some random
thing off of him amazon.com you don't
know where that thing came from right it
you're not connected to it no you know
you buy an Origin key you know what you
know exactly what's happened exactly
where it came from
you know what it means it's true you
know what it represents sure you know
that it has so yes so it's yourself an
Origin well what you're talking about is
completely correct what so I had both so
you know you're taking say making
something or doing something creating so
yes so this may or may not count so I
switch to the dorsum doorknobs in my
house big time right you see I'm saying
no but you got gratification right yeah
right satisfaction you felt good about
especially you shut that door too close
to drink yeah shut solid yeah well one
of them the locking thing was like
jammed up yet it was a thing it was just
giving me issues like given did you
overcome this state of my doorknob that
was like that wasn't any acceptable
state okay this is in my room fixing
that whole situation was like that
something that needed to be done and I
did it by myself same thing with a
different doorknob
it needed a lock it didn't have a lock
okay
so there's three altogether with
different issues some saying but okay so
I did it yes universally you overcame
overstatement did it gratification but
on top of that I shopped for the new
doorknobs on Amazon and I got
gratification from that to seem sane but
so that fact does remain but with the
ghee you have that dish the additional
gratification that not of course there
the best season in the world but they
are made in America imagine that like
you know you're a kid you want the best
car yes right yes but it's hard to
afford that car yeah or Jinky it's like
oh you want the best giko you can afford
yeah yeah you can make it happen
yeah or you could go get but they're not
the not best d up to you but I mean it's
well that's on you though yeah let's
face it that's on you that's not
encouraged behaved on man come on unless
get your ghee
or Jinky at origin mein kampf yeah and
the good thing is if you need other
clothing items outside the realm of
jiu-jitsu outside the realm of keys
outside the realm of rash guards then
you can get other clothing materials
such as t-shirts such as hoodies such as
yes jeans american-made denim yeah
same deal and you might be thinking well
why stop there don't worry we didn't
stop there you can get you can get boots
too you can get origin boots made in
America but what you know where the
leathers from though where it's from
America you know where the stitching is
from though yes it's from America but
you know where they're actually
assembled though to be honest with you
America and and then there's some some
supplementation yeah yes the most
important kind of supplements by the way
the ones that work and well in they sent
in the case of milk the kind of tastes
like dessert so yes that is the best
kind supplements in my opinion but but
joint warfare krill oil these are for
your joints keep you in the game that's
a big deal like doesn't matter how much
I just yeah that is the deal
it's the deal if you're not in the game
then you just sort of not
at all yeah like you know how like you
know the kind were you like you're super
strong but like your elbows are jamming
you up so hard like right you're not
strong no anymore because your elbows
can't take it seem sane so yeah joint
warfare krill oil also discipline this
for your brain mm-hmm brain and body
it's a brand body sort of scenario look
at you becoming every day one for me by
the way
oh you're on the D train all day or we
wait D plane discipline plane the D
plane who said that
I think Dave Burke oh is that really
good tell use a weight good do you think
I I'm pretty sure I'm not sure let me
confirm that later but nonetheless
discipline free rein every day it helps
totally does how monk helps every day
too especially when you've got that that
little post dinner do you want a little
something let's face it you let's face
it steak is awesome mm-hmm
we all know that mm-hmm but let's just
face the facts sometimes you get done
and you got that little craving yeah a
little
that little want she wants something
called dessert but you know it's not
part of the plan do you know you just
not on the program you know it is not on
the path certainly yes cake it's not on
the panel but that's okay we got you you
can have dessert you get some shelf some
bulk you also for the kids warrior kid
milk so same deal same thing same deal
but more engineered for the kids would
you say is that safe to say engineer for
the kids so we can end engineering for
the kids you know I'm not even gonna
mention it but there is an art of
artifact artifacts wrong word a product
mm-hmm that I we sampled at the Vitamin
Shoppe situation we allowed to talk
about this because it might be like
against some big reveal plan assume
saying are you talking about milk bars
it's been revealed okay
all right there you go well nonetheless
look that is gonna be like another level
even another layer of post dinner
dessert situation zoom scene yeah I do
know what you're saying because it is a
candy bar that's straight up good for
you yeah
legitimately good for you oh yeah don't
think about that doesn't taste like this
is not normal this is this is good yeah
it was different than what I was used to
do for sure unless you have any you know
buddy I have of those right now I'm in
smoke bars I have 200
oh you grabbed them all see that's where
they were super did those go cuz you
know I kind of wanted someone oh I never
want anything like I'm always like oh no
keep it no you can have it no you know
cuz alright alright that's just my kind
of my personality like I don't even want
to have that other stuff ya know I they
were like oh oh I took them all I put
them all right in my car okay all right
all those no you did the right thing I
don't want to become over building a
plant take make them yeah cuz no one
could make what we wanted yeah okay cool
you can't figure it out cool watch this
Bouldin bars
many more bars this you need anyway so
yes so mote bars not not currently
available but on the horizon on the
horizon choco whitey is available right
now yes if you need something organic in
your life because you want to feel like
one of those people that is you know
healthier healthier than you are now you
can come back at them what's almost it's
that organic actually yes it is
otherwise I wouldn't put it in my body a
certified organic what step so there you
go and by the way this stuff is all
available at the Vitamin Shoppe
nationwide which is pretty it's
convenient bottom line yeah and the only
that's not a little troubled with
convenience right because convenience
all of a sudden you know what is there a
slippery slope to McDonald's no there's
no don't let that happen
yes sir also we have a store called
Jacko's store they always said yes we
have a store we do but it's not just you
and me it's all of us we the whole
collectively everyone here as a store of
your own store yeah our own store mm-hmm
we could have called it that but we
didn't think of that back bed a store or
just you know our store the trooper
store for people that are just getting
after it anyways if you if you're
getting after it maybe you need a rash
guard maybe you need a t-shirt maybe
need a hat if your echo you don't need a
hat cuz he doesn't wear a hat
no very early I've never seen you with a
hat not even for one second not even in
the cold weather no I don't think wait
maybe I send you an origin beauty I
think you've never seen me in cold
weather oh yeah you thought I was cold
weather 1900 yeah you must add a hat on
out there I don't know if I didn't know
yeah I had a beanie oh yeah you ready oh
and the last chocolate or calm yes
represent while you're on the path
that's where you get all this cool stuff
also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already I think it's important
varying levels of importance but yeah do
it leave a review if you in the mood
it's kind of cool it's kind of a cool
thing to do to kind of like just confirm
where you're at in your mental space mmm
I think they'll forget about the
grounded podcast which is part of the
deaf core network you didn't know about
that did you
we got a whole network called the deaf
core network yeah we're building a
network sure we got free podcasts on it
Jaakko podcast grounded podcast and
warrior kid podcast yeah you can
subscribe to all of them if you want or
non of them whatever you can also check
out warrior kid soap at Irish Oaks Ranch
calm there's a kid who's been a warrior
kid since day one in the game and guess
what he makes his own soap from goat
milk goes that he raised and we have a
new soap a new soap it's called well
it's got some active ingredients that
help fight against bacteria I don't even
know what I'm talking about
well microbial microbes yeah those
funguses fungi fungi yeah all these
things all these things all those things
need to be defeated so we have a soap
and it's called killer soap and if you
use it it will help you to also YouTube
YouTube cannot be interested in the
video version of this podcast or
excerpts from the podcast you don't
necessarily want to watch the whole
thing all at once
all the time or let's just say you might
think that the world would be better
place if as the world unfolded and
things happened that part of the world
exploded or caught on fire yes cuz echo
because he has command of virtual
reality he can make my words make things
explode he can make my my kettlebell
make things blow up yes he can make his
own magical powers be revealed in forms
of like sparks if I'm so inclined yes so
that's echo Charles he may not be able
to control everything in the world but
on the jaakko youtube channel he can
make things happen
yes sir in video why sure I having these
explosions in a while but you know yeah
we're gonna continue that from time to
time I think I hope we also got an album
called psychological warfare it's a
little psychological hitter if you need
a little bump to get you over a bump you
can check that all on iTunes Google Play
or any mp3 we got flipside canvas comm
where Dakota Meyer is making visual
representations of discipline pure
distilled onto a canvas that you can
then hang on your wall and it will keep
you on the path also got a bunch of
books leadership strategy and tactics
real manual way the warrior kid got
three of those books got Mikey and the
dragons for the little kids got to
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
the audio version of that is a is on
iTunes and Amazon music and Google Play
as an mp3
we got extreme ownership and the
dichotomy of leadership the fundamentals
of combat leadership that I wrote about
with my brother lave babban we have a
shell on front which is our leadership
consultancy and what we do is we solve
problems through leadership go to a
tional on front comm if you need to help
in your organization with that we got EF
online which is online leadership
training
get you up to speed as a leader go to EF
online.com for that we've got the muster
which is our live conference gathering
seminar I got to think of a better word
cuz it's better than all those three
things every one that we've done has
sold out this year we are doing Orlando
we are doing Phoenix and we are doing
Dallas if you want to come go to extreme
ownership calm every one of these that
we have done has sold out and these are
gonna sell out too so get there earlier
and also if you need leaders at any
level in your organization check out EF
overwatch comm for executive leadership
check out EF Legion comm for frontline
leadership these are our platforms to
connect the vets that have experience
leading with companies that need
experienced leaders go check out those
platforms also wanted to say talking to
Ike asking him about any charities he
wanted me to mention and he said the
Semper Fi fund which does a bunch of
stuff for Marines for marine families
for Marines that are transitioning
outside out of the middle out of the
Marine Corps and also helps them out
with their health and wellness
so that's Semper five fund org and also
he wanted you to check out the Fisher
House which is when troops get wounded
and they're in the hospital for an
extended period of time the Fisher House
provides them with a place to sit
provides their families with a place to
stay in the area so it's Fisher House
dot org it's a grip both these
organizations are great organizations so
check those out and if you feel like you
want to hear more from echo and I you
know for whatever reason if you want to
throw a correction at us if we made a
mistake which is entirely possible we
probably need it well we're there we're
all on the interwebs and we're also on
that means we're on Twitter we're on
Instagram and we are
on the frozen bunk then you can find
echo echo Charles and I am at Jocko
willing and thanks once again to Charles
Robert Bobby Bob Eisenbach
Ike an absolute honor to meet with him
today to talk to him and hear his
incredible story of service to America
and the rest of the veterans out there
that are on active duty the ones that
have already retired that's left the
service all of you that have put on the
uniform thank you for your service and
of course the same goes out to our
police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service you
take other care of us here on the
homefront and you are appreciated as
well and to both those groups thanks to
your families for the support that you
give to the folks that are wearing the
uniform and everyone else out there you
know when you think about when you think
about the challenges that you face that
I face that we all face what challenges
are we up against what what external
power is trying to hold you down go
through your little battle your little
battle in the world and then if you can
you can remember you can remember
someone like Ike then you can remember
what he did facing these challenges shot
in the head a wounded paralyzed
hospitalized and you know what any one
of us can fold under those challenges of
life you can do that you can fold you
can give in or
you can do what I did then what I does
every day which is take on those
challenges by getting out there and
getting after it so until next time this
is echo and Jocko out